if you have an opinion do you feel free
as a citizen to share that in public or
not and if you don't I think that's an
indictment of the health of a democratic
practice the repeated pattern we now see
if it's
list of Corporations to be able to
indirectly accomplish what the
government could not directly accomplish
under the Constitution This Is The Stuff
of fascism the voice and vote we bring
to the table as an asset manager is to
mandate that companies Focus exclusively
on their products or their services do
it for profit without apologizing for it
and leave politics to the politicians
all right guys bang bang uh I thought a
great spot to start is your Twitter bio
you got uh two words Citizen and
capitalist uh why are those two things
what you identify with and like why in
that space where so many people go every
single day to see who the hell's this
guy tweeting all the stuff on the
internet that's what they read like what
is the importance of those two words
yeah I mean probably overthinking a
Twitter bio there but what was going
through my head when I wrote it is you
know I mean look there's there's this
question about what does it mean to be
American in the year 2022 and I think
being an American is a is a pretty core
part of my identity but
American is just a word what does the
actual identity mean and yeah I write
about this in one of my books but it's
been a good amount of time thinking
about it I think there are there's
basically two parts of what it means to
be an American okay I think there's the
part of our you know part of our brain
that wants to be an individual pursuing
our own individualist dream the rugged
individual the American dream through
the system of free market capitalism I
think if we're being honest there's a
side of every one of us that is that
rugged individual that wants to pursue
our own individualistic dreams full stop
and that's what it means to be American
and that's an important part of the
story
but there's also the other half and I
think that sometimes especially people
on the right but you know across the
board are afraid to admit there's the
other half but there's the other half
too that thinks of and wants to be part
of a whole that is greater than the sum
of its parts that
strives and hungers for Unity as well
and that identity as a citizen and so
the beautiful thing I think about
American identity is that it's not one
of those things it is both of those
things right I mean 1776 funny fact not
a lot of people know obviously it was
the year of the Declaration of
Independence it was also the year of The
Wealth of Nations and the way I look at
it is these These are both of our
parents right individualism and unity
capitalism and democracy the tension
between the two
is what produces this unique child of
this country we think of as America you
know myself first generation American
think of myself as an American and so
you know my way of saying that I'm
American the way I say it is I'm
capitalist and Citizen and that's what
it meant to me so when I see you
tweeting when I see you on television
when I see you uh writing things when I
see people quoting you uh I go wow that
guy's got a point of view and the point
of view is sometimes on markets
sometimes on politics sometimes on
social issues uh and it kind of cuts
across
but you run a business that is very much
an asset management firm it's literally
got Asset Management in the name that's
right the business uh talk about this
like intersection of all these different
topics where maybe our grandparents or
our great grandparents it was kind of
like hey shut up we don't want to hear
about all this other stuff like just do
your job right yeah yeah like shut up
and dribble you know type uh uh approach
versus like well now it feels like
there's like a little bit of an
information war going on around an asset
management firm but also other types of
businesses as well yeah so it's funny
because it comes full circle and there's
even a certain version of it where I
might even be hypocritical relative to
the direction I want to see the economy
go I do separate what One Believes as a
citizen from what One Believes as an
executive or a CEO or an asset manager
and so for me I think keeping those
lines straight is pretty important it's
actually I did not know that I was going
to start an asset management firm so
strives this company has started this
year brand new I thought it was done
starting businesses so I ran a biotech
company for seven years that was the
thing I did till January of 2021 and I
stepped down because I actually was
pretty bothered by the rise of you know
what I view as as this cancerous mix of
politics and business in our economy and
so that's what led me to actually say
that you know what I Can't Be an
Effective biotech CEO and by that point
you know the company had been you know
in its own world reasonably high profile
and you know had developed a number of
drugs that were on their way to approval
there was no way I was going to be the
CEO of a multi-billion dollar biotech
company and also be able to speak freely
as a citizen on the issues that I felt
that I needed to speak out on without
having an adverse impact on the business
so what I did in the beginning of 2021
was actually stepped down for my role as
CEO passed the torch to you know my good
friend who was the CFO for years he now
runs the company to say that okay I'm
going to speak as a citizen and if you
want to hear about the biotech company
great listen to Matt and and that's
that's what that's what that looked like
so I thought it was done X with my
Korean business that's when I wrote the
couple of books that I wrote I wrote
woke Inc you know we can talk about that
I wrote a sequel to woke Inc which you
know woke ink was about the merger of
business and politics and makes the case
that that's a threat to both capitalism
and democracy but there was an objection
that I never fully answered in that book
which was okay why are companies some
companies still selling this narrative
it's only they're only selling it if
people are willing to buy it you know
victimhood identities and the kinds of
one-sided Progressive agendas that were
pushed through Corporate America and so
the second book was about well asking
what it was about our cultural State and
our national psyche that caused an
entire generation you know generally
people you're my age and younger to eat
up these narratives that Corporate
America served them but anyway that's
what I thought I was doing is writing
these books
I ended up getting back to starting an
asset manager because one of the things
that one of the Epiphany moments for me
in writing these books was that you know
there is one industry that is basically
Upstream of all of the others that
directs the flow of capital into
basically all sectors of the economy and
that is the
large-scale predominantly passive Asset
Management industry
yeah three big firms dominated BlackRock
State Street and Vanguard those three
manage depending on the given day at
least as of a few months ago over 20
trillion dollars that's more than the US
GDP or on the scale of the US GDP that
were using those dollars to advance
social and political agendas that most
of the people whose money they were
investing didn't agree with or at least
many of them didn't agree with and so as
much as I enjoyed writing books and
writing on the pages of the Wall Street
Journal and and and sort of making
observations about this problem and the
threat that I thought thought it posed
to American democracy
yeah at the end of the day I built my
career up to that point as an
entrepreneur and I said you know what
I'm going to put the hat back on but
this time I'm going to start an asset
management firm that competes with those
big guys
along the axis of voice and vote so to
say that we're going to launch index
funds but the key difference is going to
be the voice and vote we bring to the
table and this is the part where it's
ironic is the voice and vote we bring to
the table as an asset manager is to
mandate that companies Focus exclusively
on their products or their services do
it for profit without apologizing for it
and leave politics to the politicians
and so in a certain way if you look at
it in a full circle sense there's a
certain way in which it's kind of a
meta-hypocrisy where I'm actually as a
citizen unconstrained and vocal on a
wide range of political cultural and
social questions but when I'm wearing my
hat as the leader of strive the sole
message I'm bringing to the table is
mandating that company's Focus
exclusively on their products and that
companies actually stay out of politics
and so that's the distinction I draw is
is you know if I'm speaking of my
capacity as an investor I'd like to
think that I have some Authority and and
maybe because of my experiences and
education and capital markets and
whatever
in the areas where I have a view maybe
my view might be better informed than
the average person whose expertise is
somewhere else but if I'm opining about
a political question or about a question
that relates to how people voted The
Ballot Box my voice absolutely does not
count anymore of any greater importance
than you know my neighbors in central
Ohio or the people I went to school
within Cincinnati or my you know former
colleagues at a hedge fund in Manhattan
everyone's voice counts equally and so
that's the kind of the distinction I
draw so when you go to these businesses
and you basically say knock off the
nonsense right stop trying to Virtue
signal and kind of do all these other
things just focus on what your business
was set out to do which is Drive profits
by serving your customers with great
products and services what's the
response are they like no no no no
that's not really what our business is
about like and they have some other
responses or is it like a thank you we
don't have to like bend the knee to
asset managers that are like pressuring
us to do things we don't want to do so
behind closed doors it's closer to the
ladder okay but my view is if you bring
a diversity of voices to the table
that's strictly a good thing right now
the thing they hear is one monolithic
voice from the especially a republic
company in the United States the big
asset managers are all pushing an agenda
wrapped around with fancy three-letter
acronyms today ESG is the chosen acronym
of the day and so so what you know if
you're going to have an influence on
underlying companies I think there are
basically three things that allow you to
have influence okay one is just the
quality of the arguments that you make
these are human beings on the other side
after all making these decisions right
the second is is just the selection of
the companies you engage with not all
companies are the same not all
Industries are the same right I mean
Elon Musk can be a new shareholder of
Twitter and bring a new shareholder
mandate to Twitter
that's harder than it sounds when you
have 10 or 15 000 employees who don't
want to do the thing that the new
shareholder wants them to do but the
inverse is true too that if you have an
industry say the oil and gas industry in
this country where people who work in
that industry including as Executives as
CEOs or as board members presumably and
it turns out I think this is true did
not actually enter that industry because
they thought they were destroying the
planet or raising an existential threat
for the future of humanity but because
they thought they were contributing to
human prosperity and human flourishing
and guess what if they've been told top
down by the other public shareholders
and I use shareholders and air quotes
because they're not the real
shareholders I'll come back to that but
if they're told by their air quotes
shareholders that they need to adopt
emissions Caps or Net Zero pledges by
2050 or scope 3 emissions reductions
plans or whatever's been imposed we can
talk about the specific examples in the
oil industry actually if somebody else
comes to the table and says you know
what if you're an oil company you should
drill you should Frack you should do do
whatever allows you to be most
successful over the long run as a
company
a lot of them are hungering for someone
to come to the table with that message
and I even think they haven't said in so
many words but I think basically they're
looking for
cover would not exactly be the word I
would use but enough latitude to say
well some of those shareholders
shareholders are saying that we need to
focus on ESG some of those shareholders
are saying we need to focus on our
exclusively on our products and services
without regard to those agendas so you
know what we're just going to make our
own business judgment and in the
industries where people who join that
industry care about those products
they're going to end up doing a better
job so that's actually the play is just
bring a diversity of voice to the table
that at least empowers the kinds of
people who are quietly thinking in the
boardroom the things that I'm saying out
loud in the letters that I'm writing to
these boards if you you see the letter I
wrote to Chevron by chance okay yes we
can talk about that one or Disney or
apple I mean explain the Chevron since
we're talking about energy yes so I
wrote a letter to the board of directors
of Chevron which you know we we you know
my firm owns a position in and the basic
message to Chevron was
listen up over the last couple of years
last the last year in particular you've
taken some interesting steps
coming out in favor of a carbon tax
coming out in favor of the Paris climate
Accords adopting scope 3 carbon
intensity targets that look like they
were the product of shareholder pressure
on your business tripling the amount of
investment into Chevron new energies
relative to what your prior targets were
and there was a turning point when when
this happened which was after a
shareholder vote in 2021 on a so-called
scope 3 emissions reduction proposal
okay so what happened in 2021 was there
was a Dutch non-profit founded by a
former refrigerator salesman in the
Netherlands and you know I respect
anyone following their passion so so as
is his right to do as a shareholder of
Chevron that non-profit put up a
proposal that proposal called for what's
called a scope 3 emissions reduction
plan at Chevron so it's a scope three
emissions reduction plan my general rule
of thumb is the more boring the
nomenclature the more you probably want
to pay attention to what it is because
yes it was designed to be Anodyne and
boring for a reason so so let's this one
sounds pretty anodized and boring that
means let's pay attention to it okay so
scope one emissions refers to your own
company's direct emissions okay scope 2
refers to indirect contributions to
emissions through your use of
electricity and power and so on
but scope 3 refers to the emissions
along your entire supply chain all the
way from your suppliers to your
customers that's not real the internet
this is this is real so scope three
emissions this is like this is the new
parlance this new Hot Topic in ESG so
what a scope 3 emissions cap requires an
oil company to do is effectively cause
its own customers to reduce the
utilization of the core product that
they sell it would be like the
equivalent of [ __ ] like not equivalent
it really would involve Chevron taking
responsibility for every unit of fuel
that it sells to Caterpillar and Chevron
is responsible for actually reducing the
emissions contribution from that fuel
without asking caterpillar or an Amazon
Prime truck or anyone else to share any
of that responsibility that makes about
as much business sense as McDonald's
voluntarily committing to reduce the
adult body weight of anyone who's eaten
a Big Mac without asking customer to
share in any of that responsibility even
if that was a desirable thing to do
right so the question I asked to the
board of Chevron was
not why is a scope 3 emissions reduction
Target in in society's best interests
that's a separate question for politics
and politicians and leave politics to
the politicians that's my philosophy
but why is it in chevron's best
interests for Chevron as a firm to adopt
this scope 3 missions cap and the funny
thing is
the non-profit the Dutch nonprofit that
proposed it they didn't claim that it
had much to do with shareholder value
what they claimed was that this is how
they what they needed to do to fight
climate change
the board of Chevron initially is a
keyword initially opposed the proposal
they thought it made such little sense
that they petitioned the SEC to leave it
off their shareholder ballot the SEC
denied that they then recommended to all
of their shareholders to vote against it
but then sloppily waddling into that
debate are none other than BlackRock
State Street and Vanguard who in 2021
voted for that scope 3 missions
reduction plan and so the question and
then by the way and now these
shareholder resolutions are technically
non-binding so the board can still take
its own action but very few times where
you find a board that stands up to a
majority shareholder vote that goes in a
given Direction and so what do you see
the board doing they you know adopt the
tripling of of their target to Chevron
new energies which is you know I don't
think competes is unlikely even based on
things they've said on their own right
to definitively compete for Returns on
Capital with the rest of their core oil
and gas business you have a number of
steps that they took in the public
adoption of scope 3 intensity targets
the public Embrace of the Paris climate
accorded the public Embrace of a carbon
tax a lot of which was emphasized
following this shareholder vote so our
point was okay that's the voice those
shareholders are bringing to the table
we have a post ESG mandate and our post
ESG mandate is that you autofocus
exclusively on what maximizes long-run
value for your shareholders that scope 3
emissions Target as best we can tell
makes no business sense we'd like to see
you rescind that scope 3 emissions
Target now here's the rub right it's
hard for you to do that when your other
shareholders are pressuring you in this
direction
you want to know the mystery at the
heart of this the people who claim to be
your shareholders
BlackRock State Street Vanguard they're
not the actual Capital owners of your
firm the actual Capital owners
are the everyday citizens whose money is
being managed by BlackRock State Street
and Vanguard and irony at the heart of
this all right is that those firms and
firms like them I mean Invesco is no
better in my opinion but these firms
have aggregated massive assets
largely because they said we're going to
offer you low fees through these
passively managed index funds because
we're too dumb to pick your stocks okay
we're too dumb to pick stocks we'll just
give you a low fees and this is not a
crazy idea I mean good logic behind this
we're not going to beat the market we're
going to give you very low fees to offer
you exposure to the market
but the very people who said we're too
dumb to pick stocks have somehow become
sagacious enough to know how to design
an entire social Universe weaponizing
the money of everyday citizens to do it
and the irony is that they're using the
money of everyday citizens many of whom
even disagree with the underlying
agendas that they're pushing with their
own money so our view is look if you
want to advance an environmental agenda
or a social agenda with your own money
you're free to do that this is a free
country and you can invest accordingly
strive would not be a good home for your
capital and that's cool right this is a
free country diverse opinions we ought
to have those diverse opinions
represented by the diversity of people
who wield their Capital accordingly
but
if you want with your money to deliver a
message to Corporate America that's
exclusively focused on maximizing your
bottom dollar and say you know what I
might be on the left I might be on the
right I want you to make as much money
as I can so that I have enough to
support the causes I want to support my
private life another way well for you we
would hope that strive is actually is
hopefully a good home and that was what
that was what the premise was for
launching strive but it's also been the
premise for some of the public
charitable letters I've written to
Chevron and and some of these other
companies and I should say by the way I
mean Mike worth the CEO of Chevron he
responded that night Curtis reply he
asked his CFO and other Executives who
who offered a fly out to meet we you
know I think the next week had an
extensive dinner where we you know had a
healthy Exchange
that is what's missing in corporate
America's boardrooms today is right now
if you have the view that I'm
articulating you shut up and keep it to
yourself
if you have the prevailing ESG Orthodoxy
behold and view great you voiced that
and then there's a disproportionate air
time with respect to who gets airtime in
that public debate be it in the
boardroom or be in our Capital markets
that creates the illusion that this is
actually what most people want when in
fact there's a big asymmetry between
what most Capital owners actually want
versus the capital owners who are
actually willing to speak up actually
say they want and and I think that
that's what tilts the scales of public
debate so when you write a letter like
that to Chevron you said that uh the CEO
responded he is responding publicly or
privately and he replied on email I
meant I sent send it to him by email he
replied to me privately by email
he was on Bloomberg TV I think like the
next day when he was I was on CNBC that
the next morning he was on you know or
whatever what could you know that week
whenever it was he was on Bloomberg TV
and he was asked about it and I
appreciated some things he said I mean I
think that people generally expect you
to criticize and you know a so-called
apparently activist investor
I forget exactly what he said it was
basically at the end of the universe to
the effect of you know there's him
speaking that saying that you know look
I want to take a more balanced I've been
trying to take a more balanced approach
to this energy debate and engagements
like this help us take a more balanced
approach I said okay great I'm glad to
hear him saying that because that's part
of the point is to by bringing a diverse
voice to the table and a diverse mandate
to the table you know I intentionally
use the word diverse here because
there's a there's been a monopolization
of what diversity means in Corporate
America we bring a diverse voice to the
table diversity of thought to the
boardroom then you know what good things
can happen and so in that sense I'm a
big believer in diversity that's
actually what's been missing and so when
the executives come out and they have
dinner with you and I'm using them as
just an example but I'm assuming they're
they engage in conversations when you
write these letters uh across a bunch of
different
um kind of engagements uh what are they
seeking are they are they like oh we
never thought of this are they uh okay
you know help us understand your
Viewpoint like what is that conversation
there's a multi-hour dinner in this case
was I happen to be in the middle of uh I
think they offered to come out to Ohio
where I am I happen to be in New York
that next week launching my launching my
second book so I was in the middle of
the book tour but we said we'd take an
evening in the middle of the book tour
and and you know have dinner with these
guys so the CFO and then there was
another executive from their team you
know had dinner they booked up a place
and you know I I you know
showing up at 7 30 or whatever they were
both there and we spent a few hours
together and the purpose it seemed to me
was to actually hear the view to
actually understand what was the premise
of this engagement what was behind this
view to give them a chance to respond to
some of those arguments and my sense was
they agreed with certain things they had
a different point of view on other
things but I think that one of the
things that was interesting to me about
about you know the range of engagements
we've had not just this one is that
there's such pressure on these companies
to justify the steps they've taken
in the language of long-run shareholder
value
when in fact for many of these socially
motivated actions long-run shareholder
value had a little to do with it now why
is that we have this fiduciary cannon in
this country fiduciary duty fiduciary
law in this country that says that if
you're an asset manager investing
someone else's money or even if you're a
member of a board of directors or an
executive who was a fiduciary duty to
shareholders you have to operate with
what's called a sole interest it's
called the sole interest rule which says
that your sole interest has to be to
maximize long run value if it's your
sole interest that means there's no room
for mixed motivations
maximize long run value and X long run
value and Y no there is no and x and and
Y if you're operating under the sole
interest rule that that's a pretty
demanding standard and I think there's
reasonable room for debate about whether
that standard should even be framed the
way it is that's a public policy debate
I have views on this
nonetheless that's what the sole
interest rule demands and so if you want
to get to the heart of what happened I
think over the last 10 years or so and I
think a lot of this dated back to the
2008 financial crisis and I can talk
about that at length but on the back of
the 08 financial crisis anyway this
trend began
what happened was there was a a newly
ascendant camp in public discourse about
the future of American capitalism that
said that you know the greatest good
Mantra didn't work that's what got us
into the 08 financial crisis I I
disagree with that diagnosis but
nonetheless that's a it's a worthy point
of view and say we need something new
out of American capitalism and you know
what Milton Friedman who in 1970
famously said that you know the social
purpose of a corporation is to pursue
profit he missed something
and this is this is I think the most
powerful argument in favor of the ESG
movement and stakeholder capitalism it's
an argument that deserves to be
carefully considered okay what they said
is Milton Friedman never responded to
the following and they're right he never
responded to this
which is the idea that you know what in
that state of nature that the
libertarian fantasizes about
there was no such thing as limited
liability what what is limited liability
limited liability is a legal creation
it's a law it's a set of laws that
basically say that the owners of a
corporation the shareholders of a
corporation are not liable for the debts
or other liabilities of that Corporation
legal claims made against it and so on
but they enjoy all of the upside all of
the profits that come out of that
corporation's activities that doesn't
exist in the state of nature it's a
legal creation and so so the argument
for stakeholder capitalism goes as it
goes is that you know what
there's a quid pro quo there's a grand
bargain at the birth of the American
corporation which says that in return
for those great gifts that Society
bestowed upon corporations and their
shareholders like limited liability
we have an ask and the ask is that you
corporations and shareholders have to at
least be
charitable in taking those social
responsibilities into account too you
have to act in society's best interests
at times especially when it comes to
containing your negative externalities
and you know what that's part of the
grand bargain the social bargain that
allows Capital to exists
I don't actually agree with that view
but I respect that view it's a worthy
View
I think that the legal history is mostly
wrong there okay so so for that the
actual legal history and I traced this
in woke Inc is actually the fact that
there was a grand bargain
at the Inception of the American
corporation codified an American
corporate law but it wasn't the one
presupposed by the stakeholder
capitalist that it was an unspoken Grand
bargain they say no no this was an
explicit Grand bargain it's written into
the law and the explicit Grand bargain
is in return for these great gifts like
limited liability which would otherwise
make corporations incredibly powerful
you're shielded from liability while
corporate shareholders you know enjoy
all the upside with that great power
comes a responsibility to stay in your
lane
to actually you can be Frankenstein's
monster but Frankenstein's monster has
to stay in his cage the cage of the
market without wielding undue power over
the political process by engaging in a
wide range of social political issues
and there's great proof for that in the
legal history actually back in the day
you know 1800s even early 1900s if you
got a charter from the state to have a
corporation a charter gives you the
benefits like limited liability which
you would need in order to raise money
if you went beyond the charter that the
state granted you let's say a charter to
be a bridge building company and you try
to build a toll road instead you lose
those benefits so they say you lose your
limited liability and you lose all this
if you go beyond the narrow purpose for
which that Corporation got its Charter
over the years that got expanded to any
profit-seeking activity
but that was that was baked into the
grand bargain so anyway that's woking
stuff and you know legal history I can
tell you about but back to the argument
for stakeholder capitalism so even
though I disagree with it it's at least
a coherent view that deserves careful
consideration and debate that's what
Larry Fink is a CEO of BlackRock I
believe it is what he meant when he
repeatedly said for years that
businesses have to earn their social
license to operate every day refers to
this idea of the grand bargain between
businesses in society
there's something interesting that
happened in the last couple of years
like this is the last you know 12 to 24
months a lot of this I think is in
response to the arguments I made in my
book in woking and elsewhere so I made I
made the counter case and I expected you
know I'm a big believer in get the best
ideas on the table be open to changing
your mind if a better one comes along
you know your ideas aren't like your
kids okay if a better one comes along
you can just take it instead right more
like a set of clothes you try it on now
that something else fits better you try
that on instead I bring I try to bring
that attitude to the table I hope my my
you know peers in public discourse do
the same so I was waiting for maybe
maybe there's a better idea maybe
there's a better counter argument to the
case that I made
it turns out that the other side made a
really interesting move they didn't come
back with a different argument what they
said is instead
no actually
um forget everything we said before we
didn't really mean that stakeholder
capitalism is really just capitalism
it's just about long run value so all
that stuff about earning the social
license to operate in the quid pro quo
and the grand bargain at the Inception
of the corporation now
forget about that you don't know why
because they're in-house lawyers told
them actually there's the sole interest
rule in the fiduciary duty in the United
States demands that you actually act in
financial interest so he was kind of
right about that and you know if you
keep saying this you're going to get
you're going to get us in trouble so
they said okay actually you know what
disregard that it's just about long run
Financial value and so what happens is
you then get these shareholder proposals
like that Dutch non-profit whose
motivation has nothing to do with
long-run financial value
it's about addressing climate change
worthy goal perhaps but nonetheless okay
that's a not a goal that relates to the
best interests of Chevron as a business
and the board of Chevron initially says
that okay yeah we agree that's not in
the best long-run shelter interest so we
stand against the proposal so if you've
just flash freeze that the guy who is in
favor of the proposal and the board is
against it agree on one thing which is
it has nothing to do with long run
shareholder value yet when BlackRock and
Vanguard on State Street waddle in and
then have to vote and then choose to
vote in favor of that proposal they have
to justify it and then the management
team and board of Chevron which then
been the need of BlackRock at State
Street have to change their story to say
that no no actually never mind this is
just about long run value maximization
that is a farce it is a lie I believe
it's mostly you know intellectual Jiu
Jitsu that that has no Truth at its core
by the way but say the same thing in
apple just as a side note I've been
wrote a short letter to Apple there was
about a racial Equity audit proposal
okay the group that was advancing the
racial Equity audit proposal at Apple
one of their stated objectives is to
hold companies like apple accountable
for their role in perpetuating white
supremacy Noble goal perhaps debate for
another day I have my views on that too
but that's as is their right Apple's
board initially said that doesn't make
very much sense for us to adopt so thank
you very much we won't
but then waddling in our BlackRock and
State Street in that case that vote in
favor of it that's just this year in
2022 vote in favor of it nonetheless and
then Apple lo and behold months later is
now conducting a racial Equity audit and
so I think we should just be honest
about what the motivations are maybe
businesses
shouldn't just focus on maximizing
overall value but if that's the case
let's have that debate but instead I
think failing to win that debate what
this Camp did instead the pro-esg camp
is they completely changed their
justification in tune to say that
actually wasn't about making Society a
better place it was just about long run
value maximization all along which just
introduces this dishonesty in the debate
and confuses the public as to what's
actually going on and so what I'm trying
to do with these you know shareholder
letters and engagements with boards Etc
is pierced through that okay where it's
a farce let's actually get into the
specifics and smoke out what's actually
going on because once you smoke out
what's actually going on we can all
agree or disagree and some of us might
agree and others might disagree but at
least we can understand exactly what
we're debating as opposed to creating
the smoke screen which I think leaves us
all worse off so
one of my big questions here is you guys
have 400 million dollars give or take in
assets uh many of these other
organizations have trillions yes
uh why are they responding to you like
is it the power of the idea is it uh the
fear that you're going to whip up you
know public support is it they reply to
everybody who writes them a letter like
like why do you think it is that whether
Chevron or I don't know if apple or
others you know I've responded like why
are they engaging given you know in the
grand scheme of things you guys are
still growing but small compared to the
black rocks and I mean so we launched
our first Fund in August right so I
would say one thing is I think you know
most people who are who will be in the
industry would tell you if you have a
firm that launches its first Fund in
August and then it's at you know or 400
million dollars by whatever mid uh
mid-october where we are right now two
months later uh you know that's that's
considered to be actually kind of the
Velocity well yeah I mean more I mean I
think it would defy industry Norms but
it's tiny in the scheme of of the
multi-trillion dollar asset managers
that are out there so like I said I
think these are human beings on the
other side human beings I think are
persuaded by arguments I mean you can
read the Chevron letter and and judge
for yourself what you think about the
quality of the arguments made in that
letter but you know I have spent you
know some some time on this over the
last couple years analyzing these issues
you could read woke Inc you can you know
evaluate with the quality and merits of
the arguments are in their own right
you know every reader can come to their
own judgment but that's a factor that
independently matters irrespective of
the weight of capital behind it I think
a lot of people forget that right I
think that at the end of the day when it
comes to debating ideas
the quality of the ideas and the
arguments that back them up inherently
have value in their own right okay
then I think you know a selection of of
which companies you engage with look I
think Twitter is not Chevron
I think that there are companies that in
many cases I mean Exxon appears to be a
company that also had Bend its knee
after an activist campaign and that and
that actually brings me to to the next
point which is Exxon in part bent its
knee on the back of an activist campaign
run by a tiny shareholder engine number
one who led an activist campaign that
then got BlackRock and and others on
board but nonetheless influenced
America's largest Energy company a
company that as recently as 2013 was the
largest company in the world by market
capitalization sign up people forget
that and now it's whatever Apple
Facebook Google or no not Facebook
whatever Apple Amazon Google and uh
Apple Amazon Google Microsoft those are
those four four US tech companies and
then Saudi aramco are are the top five
as at least as of a month ago
get as recently as 2013 it was Exxon and
exxon's own Direction was changed by a
tiny activist investor
that had its own success I explained
this uh what kind of what happened here
right because I think this is like a
very interesting one and then maybe
we'll talk about Netflix which kind of
you know changed its course then and now
it's almost reversed this course a
little bit but on the Exxon example uh
business is the largest business in the
world uh an activist investor shows up
tiny in size uh makes a lot of noise and
kind of persuasive arguments what does
Exxon do differently and then how did
that impact the business today's episode
is brought to you by Alto I alright have
you wanted to buy Bitcoin or over 200
other cryptocurrencies in your
retirement account well now you can with
Alto Ira they allow you to buy Bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies in a tax advantage
way there's no account or setup fees and
it's super simple to get started you can
go today to Alto ira.com to get started
Alto ira.com
invest in Bitcoin or cryptocurrencies in
your retirement account and get all the
tax advantages while still holding
digital currencies Alto ira.com yeah so
so they
um basically put new directors on the
board of Exxon to vote for a revised
change in its climate change strategy so
when BlackRock cast its decisive vote to
say they're going to vote for three of
those dissident directors it was
basically a done deal that there's going
to be a new board at the table at Exxon
and who makes the decision inside of
these large organizations managers so
opaque it is so opaque so they have
these governance departments these
stewardship teams but it's like you know
if people talk about the Deep state in
government this is like deep corporate
within the private sector right like
these are the people they they're not
the ones with skin in the game many of
them aren't even professional investors
they're professional bureaucrats hired
within the so-called governance
Departments of these organizations the
shareholder stewardship or shareholder
engagement arms whatever each firm calls
it that are professionally making the
decisions to say that this is the right
thing that the company must do is that a
problem that it's not the investors
making the decision and it's something
somebody else I think it's part of the
problem absolutely now some firms are
saying that they would take more input
from their portfolio managers who are at
least closest to the Investments I mean
if you had to pick that's definitely a
better approach right now now I think
that if if you are optimizing for
shareholder values but if you're
optimizing for other things maybe it's
not the best it's not the best exactly
and so that's actually making a
statement and again that gets back to
the debate that's going on is maybe
businesses shouldn't actually optimize
for shareholder value it's not my view
but but that could be a coherent view
but if that's what's going on that's
definitely consistent with the way the
behaviors have played out with the way
those organizations are structured but
then they claim after the fact and wrap
it in the veneer of long-termism or
whatever but yeah there's there's
basically professional bureaucrats a lot
of people who are populating these new
ESG ranks are basically people who
bring the technical appearance of doing
Finance right it's like it's like a you
know guy Goldman's daughter or whatever
son or daughter that would have
otherwise gone to work at a non-profit
or Greenpeace or whatever and then they
say oh no you don't have to do that
anymore you can actually just go do that
Greenpeace stuff inside the private
sector and I can be more more proud of
you because I think you have a real job
and then they join the ESG department
where they probably don't know how to
run a discounted cash flow analysis of
how you actually value a firm but they
do know how to create spreadsheets and
they knew that you do a discounted cash
flow analysis on a spreadsheet so it
feels like I'm doing Finance like I'm
making a spreadsheet for a different
thing I'm doing ESG scoring on the
spreadsheet and so it creates this
illusion of oh yeah yeah those people
who did Finance I'm doing Finance now
too except it's actually has nothing to
do with the actual Financial attributes
of assessing the value of a firm but the
veneer the look and feel of Finance the
the quasi-rigger associated with
investment analysis to bring that
masquerade to actually just implementing
what is a political or social agenda
that they would have otherwise done at
you know at a non-profit or at a
political organization so it's kind of a
funny cultural thing that's happening
yeah so this is fascinating because uh I
don't think that any large asset manager
is all Democrats all Republicans uh or
frankly it's probably not even 50 50.
there's people who have all kinds of uh
uh differing views uh some of them think
American politics are stupid right yeah
some people think that uh that is
literally life and death right that's
right uh do they have disagreements
internally on some of these issues I
think they do
um I think that there's especially now
that it's resulting in in backlash to
these organizations I think that there
is more dialogue at least and I'm
talking very recently I think coming up
in the ranks of these big asset managers
we've recruited some people out of and
we had two co-heads we took out of State
Street who joined strive that run our
institutional business now
they clearly did not agree with the
direction that states treated well
what's interesting is because you're
providing the diversity of opinion and
thought inside of the boardroom and now
they can sit there and say well this
group of shareholders thinks hey this
group of shareholders thanks B we've
talked about what the pros and cons of
that are but if you also provide an
opinion a different opinion inside of
the asset management firms in some way I
think of it as career uh um like uh
cover you're allowing people now to
voice the opinion that may have
otherwise been quiet and what it does is
it creates dialogue discussion debate
and people who disagree with the other
side will say that's bad right but I
think the objective view would be well
don't we want people to discuss and
debate which way should we vote before
we vote rather than just say we're
always going to vote one way on every
single topic uh because it is a social
or political you know leaning so so I
will say this I mean it's one of the
things I said in the opening to my first
book Is I think the best measure measure
of the health of any Democratic Society
is the percentage of people who feel
free to say what they actually think in
public
how is it matters how is America doing
on that I think we're doing pretty
poorly is the answer to that question I
think I I believe I agree we might we
might have hit our we made it we might
have hit our neighbor in like the summer
of 2020 through 20 summer of 2021 that
might have been the low point I think
we're on the beginning of a rebound
actually and I feel good about that and
whatever small role I have played in
that that that's probably one of the
most important things I've done I think
about a pendulum but I think that that's
but more of us need but we need it's
it's a little bit of a pendulum right
swinging back you know so swinging back
and this is this is something I talk
about in my more recent book too is
people do analogize you know even I did
this before I refresh myself on the
history analogize the rise and fall of
the American experiment to the rise and
fall of the Roman Empire if you actually
study the history of Rome there wasn't
one rise in one fall there were many
rises in many Falls and I think the same
goes if you take a careful study of
American History too right there were
many rises in many Falls and so you know
I think I think we might have hit a
Nader on this attribute that I think is
the I think is the most important
Hallmark for democracy people think it's
about there's a lot of discussion these
days about our democracy what does it
mean to defend our democracy people I
think some ways fetishize the number of
ballots that are cast every November and
I'm not saying that's not important
but that's just that's just the final
act at the end of the process the real
litmus test of the health is if you have
an opinion
do you feel free as a citizen to share
that in public or not and if you don't
I think that's an indictment of the
health of a Democratic Society so so
part of my mission this is even
pre-strived just as a human being what
is part of the impact I want to have on
the country in the world is at least to
create the space where we close that gap
between what you believe in private and
what you're what you're willing to say
in private and what you're willing to
say in public the smaller that Gap is
the healthier our body politic is the
healthier Capital markets are the
healthier system of American capitalism
is that I I could I think that's I think
it's I mean we could we could just talk
about that for hours and I think that
just to close the BlackRock theme up for
a second one of the things the story
would be incomplete
if I didn't know one of the reasons why
they're doing what they're doing okay
is that some of their clients actually
want them to be doing it in fairness
right you know the state streets and
vanguards and blackrocks of the world
will tell you our clients are demanding
it they're not they're not totally wrong
about that
so Calpers the pension fund in
California and you know New York Pension
funds or whatever and I'm
I've been traveling so much I'm losing
track where we are like are we in
California we're not we're in Florida
but you know Florida's very different
but but you know CalPERS in New York
they're
effectively demanding that these asset
managers adopt these values and what
they say is we're not going to do
business with you
unless you adopt a firm wide commitment
to the Paris climate Accords to Modern
diversity Equity inclusion standards to
Net Zero pledges Etc so what that means
is a firm wide commitment means not only
with our money but with everyone else's
money too you have to vote accordingly
see that's where that's where this hit a
rub which is you know put yourself in
BlackRock or state streets shoes these
are Big clients they're demanding it
they want me to be a signatory of the
climate action 100 plus Network look
that one up right it's it's a horizontal
Network representing 68 trillion dollars
of assets under management globally
majority market share in the global
Asset Management industry usually if the
actors with majority market share in the
sector get together and sign a common
set of commitments that affect consumers
we have a word for that we call that an
Anti-Trust violation or price fixing
violation but somehow today we call that
ESG if it's the climate action 100 plus
Network's pledge has anyone gone after
it from an Anti-Trust just started to
very recently so Arizona's attorney
general has opened up an investigation I
think numerous other states are are
expressing concern about this as well so
so that's a whole separate you know
angle here I think I think the title of
his op-ed in the Wall Street Journal was
that ESG may be the largest antitrust
violation hiding in plain light and they
might have been the opening line of his
piece I didn't get a good argument for
it
I've spoken extensively about this as
well but anyway that's part of the
reason guiding this behavior is there's
there's a cynical economic Force lurking
behind the scene too which is you know
in the way this basically goes is Europe
adopts some disastrous energy policy
that caused them to live a second world
lifestyle Californians think it's cool
to be like Europe so California adopts
those disastrous policies but they don't
want to be uncompetitive as a state so
they use their pension fund dollars to
make sure that the private sector is the
vehicle and investment dollars are used
as the vehicle to insure the rest of the
country suffers their same fate that's
what we're seeing basically in this
so-called green energy Revolution that
we're watching unfold in plain sight is
as a as a you know slow motion disaster
but anyway that's part of what's driving
this too is it's not just the culture of
fear there's an economic component to
this but but anyway back to the more
important point is I just think that
I just think that our Capital markets
are better off corporate decision making
is better off and American democracy is
better off if people don't feel like
they have to choose between the First
Amendment and the American dream between
speaking their minds freely and putting
food on the dinner table say if you're
an employee at one of these firms or an
executive at one of the underlying
companies but where people feel like
their experience of being a citizen part
and parcel of it is being able to
disagree in the open to dissent with a
prevailing view that's I think that the
real the real thing that matters we
started conversation about what it means
to be American I think that's that's a
pretty darn important part about what it
means to be American and I think we've
been missing it for a few years
so when these Pension funds are doing
this right it's kind of interesting
because you have companies that are
receiving pressure from Asset Management
firms the asset management firms have
very opinionated views in terms of what
they want the companies to do but then
they point and they say oh that's
because our pension fund people are
telling us to do that do the pension
fund people say like yep I am the CIO
the director the you know executive at
the pension fund and this is what I
believe we should do or they then kind
of passing you know the hot potato and
saying oh no our pensioneers are the
ones who are demanding it like how far
back does it go I think we're getting
pretty close to where the buck stops but
but then what they do is they just point
all around them so there's just like
everywhere it's a pointing game at
somebody else so you know s p or Moody's
or you know Morningstar these are
ratings kind of agencies they're
adopting these ESG factors and so
they'll say this is the way the world is
going so we're just guiding the
underlying asset managers to go in the
direction the world is already going so
I talked about the climate action 100
plus network of asset managers there's a
very similar
industry Association of Consultants
indeed the very pension fund Consultants
who tell Pension funds where to invest
and that horizontal industry Association
says they will not make a recommendation
to a pension fund to allocate dollars to
an asset manager that isn't a signatory
of the climate action 100 plus Network
or that isn't on board with the Paris
climate Accords and so it becomes a one
giant circular reference but you're
right the asset managers are basically
pointing Upstream to say this is what
our clients are demanding so there's a
funny little story about this even the
last few weeks
so so a bunch of I think like 19 State
Attorneys General generally from I think
red States sent a letter to Blackrock
saying that they were concerned with
BlackRock using its investment dollars
it's client dollars to pressure oil
companies to reduce production then
BlackRock issued a response you know
some number of weeks later they said up
you guys are wrong we're not doing that
we don't use
money client funds that we manage for
clients to pressure oil companies to
reduce production just wrong you got it
wrong there's a refutation
within a week
the Comptroller of the city of New York
says that you know what I find
blackrock's response alarming that's the
way to use alarming and basically that's
not what you told us
that's not the commitment you made to us
so in a certain sense you you just see
you see a bifurcation in this market is
inevitable okay you have clients with
diverse interests it's like you know I
went to law school as well along the
ways part of my you know winding
background but you know basic Point law
school you can't represent the plaintiff
and the defense in the same case it's a
basic shocking yeah shocking especially
if you're gonna be a vocal Advocate you
can't vocally be an advocate for the
plaintiff in the defense well I'm not
sure that California and Texas have
aligned interests on energy policy right
now and the energy policies that are in
part implemented really through the
companies that operate respectively in
in those States well if you have clients
with fundamentally different underlying
interests I don't think you can be a
vocal Financial fiduciary for those
clients with Divergent interests at the
same time if one state wants you to
pursue profit and another state wants
you to pursue social agendas that are
orthogonal to profit you can't be a good
fiduciary to both at the same time if
you're only bringing one voice to the
table so are the Pension funds that
disagree with the way the asset managers
are voting or their perspectives are
they not pulling their assets because
there's no alternative or are they
simply uh they don't want to rock the
boat or they are thinking it in private
but if they pull the funds then that's
basically a public expression of their
Viewpoint like why is it yeah it's a
good California in Texas if they have
diverse views but the asset manager
which is kind of a central point of
failure if you own this system is voting
One Way well obviously one of those two
State Pension funds disagrees with the
way that the vote goes and so why is the
dissenting voice not pulling the funds
short answer is it's starting to happen
slowly right so so that even this issue
it's people forget that sometimes
it's a relatively recent issue right I
mean BlackRock only changed its posture
on voting you know using aggressive
social agendas in its voting practices
starting I think like 2018. and in 2018
is when a lot of this ESG steam picked
up a new fervor okay why 2018 I don't
know but I think Donald Trump had
something to do with it he pulled out of
the Paris climate Accords or sort of
rejected joining the Paris climate of
course for some reason there was
something about that moment that really
caused this Behavior to pick up so
excuse me that's not that long ago right
it takes a couple Cycles to even see
what voting behavior looked like around
then he was firing off tweets talking
about Little Rocket Man and our North
Korean dictator friend right yeah
exactly like doing the whole thing there
was something about Donald Trump right
that just made everyone yeah especially
the people political understand lose
their ability to otherwise engage in
constructive rational thoughts smart
intelligent often even brilliant people
it's like it's like you hit them with
like mad cow disease or something like
that they just lose their ability to
think and process thoughts as a grown
adult human being it goes back to your
comment about democracy like now uh
somehow in public discourse almost on a
daily basis I see someone on one of the
sides of the aisle talking about threat
to our democracy yeah and I'm like
there's a lot of threats to democracy
that just popped up over the last four
years five years right the race to
democracy are plural yeah and you know
the people who are most fervent uh
wherever they're on the debate the most
fervent
Defenders of our democracy are almost
uniformly posing a significant threat to
it that they fail to see themselves I
think this merger of state power and
corporate power that we're seeing in the
last four years including between large
Tech firms and and the government I mean
this is this is to me where the biggest
threat to democracy lies okay explain
yeah I mean look I mean I think most of
what's going on in the private sector
today this is between the ESG debate but
I also think it's true about censorship
on the Internet it's all part of this
broad discussion we're having
is effectively the government
using private companies to do through
the back door
what the government could not get done
directly through the front door under
the Constitution this is frightening
stuff right so so if you take a look at
like you know this guy I mean I don't I
don't know him but this guy Alex
Berenson or whatever was taken out on
Twitter okay I mean my full extent of
knowing the guys exchanges on Twitter
never met him outside of it all right
but as I could care less about defending
what he said or not I don't even have a
view on the content of what he said that
caused him to get taken down but
whatever Twitter shut down his account
what we discovered in recent months was
that that happened after the White House
specifically pressured Twitter to take
down his account
she's sort of just pause on that first
explicitly said his account there's a
meeting that Twitter Executives have are
having in the White House and they're
asked multiple times why haven't you
shut down
Alex Berenson by name
This Is The Stuff of founding fathers
rolling over in their graves what did
Alex Branson do he was a Critic of the
government
so the government
censoring critics of the government this
is the paradigmatic First Amendment
violation that the founding fathers had
in mind when they wrote the thing called
the First Amendment it's pretty damn
important that's why they called it the
First Amendment to the Constitution of
the United States all right so now it's
even worse though it's not the
government
is censoring those people because
there's a pesky thing called you know
dog out of the founding fathers put that
first amendment and this is gonna be
kind of hard to do here's what we'll do
we use private companies and use threats
to those private companies and give them
some carrots too you got to have the
velvet glove as well combination of of
inducements and threats
to get them to do what we can't do to
give them our dirty work because they're
not bound by the First Amendment
This Is The Stuff of fascism fascism
classical definition of fascism is the
merger of state power and corporate
power to do what neither could do on its
own the state deputizing the workings of
Industry to effectuate the state's
agenda
and you see that by the way in the
environmental agenda as well right the
green New Deal couldn't pass Congress no
problem we'll just get John Kerry to go
around and you know travel around a
private jet to meet the banking CEOs of
this country and pressure them into
signing the climate pledge which
includes some of the same policy
objectives of the green New Deal that
they couldn't pass through Congress
why is it that Alaskan drilling doesn't
take place there's no Arctic drilling
almost no financing for Arctic drilling
is it because it's illegal not quite
it's because every financial institution
in this country every mainstreamed major
financial institution has signed the
climate pledge
banks are not charitable institutions
the question is what are they getting in
return right and this gets to your world
a little bit here about about the
corruption of of even centralized
Finance but that's that's another topic
the thing I'm talking about is
the repeatable but the repeated pattern
we now see in the private sector is the
use of Corporations and asset managers
and financial institutions included in
that
to be able to indirectly accomplish what
the government could not directly
accomplish under the Constitution
and I find that to be you don't talk
about threats to democracy that I think
is the single greatest threat to
democracy today I mean it goes different
people use different words you know it's
what Klaus Schwab the founder of the
world economic Forum calls the great
reset it's the dissolution of boundaries
between the public sector and the
private sector to do what actually
neither one could do on its own
you know this is the good version of
this is
solving shared Global challenges that
government could not itself address on
its own that the private sector needs to
step up to the plate that misinformation
and hate speech and the perpetuation of
disinformation online and the the
challenges of a warming planet for the
future of humanity governments are not
doing enough and so this is what
requires us to dissolve the boundaries
between public and private institutions
to address these issues together I mean
I agree or not that's the view right
that's the view of the world economic
performance the cloud Schwab view it is
the view of the proponents of
stakeholder capitalism it is the view of
the proponents of the great reset let's
debate that because I find I shudder at
that world in which that boundary
between the public and private sectors
is dissolved that's exactly where we
find ourselves today and we talk about
threats to our democracy by the very
people who are perpetuating that agenda
that's why I say actually you might want
to actually take a look in the mirror
and and you know engage in some
introspection in terms of what
contribution you're making to fueling
the so-called threats to our democracy
as well how much is that blending uh
received in a positive way by Executives
at whether they're private companies
Asset Management firms or whatever
because there seems to be a revolving
door between the people from those
organizations going into positions of
power and influence in the government
and back it's so so it's worse than the
revolving door it's it's so how much is
influencing it absolutely but it's even
worse it's like the revolving door is
the second best option the first best
option is you don't even have to
go into government to exercise political
power so I was at a dinner a couple
years ago with uh Jamie dimon um there
was a Founders Forum or whatever they
whatever they call it to get a bunch of
you know young up and coming companies
CEOs in a room together with you know
the big guy Jamie dimon Big Marketing
event that JP Morgan runs and so this is
back when I was CEO of the biotech
company that I founded so I was there in
that capacity but he's spouting off
about one political topic after another
and so somebody says hey you know Jamie
would you ever consider running for
president he doesn't miss a beat first
thing he says is uh
of course I would want to be president
I just don't want to go through the
process of running for president and
everyone in the room laughs not because
it was so obviously false but because it
was so obviously true and you know
there's a certain honesty in what he
said too which is that I want to
exercise quasi-political power without
the inconveniences of actually being
politically accountable
that's the Jamie Diamond problem it is
the Larry Fink problem it is the ESG
industrial complex at its finest which
is the use of political power using
Capital as a force to effectuate
normative agendas that ought to be
settled through free speech and open
debate in the Public Square where every
Citizen's voice and vote counts equally
and to me that's the main problem with
stakeholder capitalism what capitalism
ESG influenced capitalism whatever you
want to call it that's my main problem
with it
it's not just the Milton Friedman
problem okay I mean I love the guy but
but he only got half the story in my
opinion yeah is it going to lead
companies to be maybe less effective at
making widgets for profit if they're
distracted by their social issues sure
but that's that's old 1980s stuff well
asked and answered okay
my problem is the inverse
the problem I have is that what this
stakeholder capitalist ESG capitalism
movement demands
is that the guys with the goals get to
make the rules okay the guys who wield
Capital set the rules for not only
whether it's this bottle of water that
rises to the top in the marketplace for
products and by the way I'm fine with
that that's how capitalism works it's
not a one-person one-vote system it is a
one dollar one vote system and that's
okay that's how the market rules work in
the marketplace for products and
services
but in the marketplace of ideas how and
whether to fight systemic racism how and
whether to combat global climate change
I mean these are fundamental normative
questions where every Citizen's voice
and vote
ought to count equally
regardless of the number of dollars the
number of green pieces of paper they
control in the marketplace
and I think what the stakeholder
capitalism movement does it is it
conflates the rules of the market that
say that my dollars decide whether my
iPhone or my Samsung phone Rises to the
top of the market or this bottle of
water or the shares of who get voted in
terms of who gets to be on the board of
directors of Apple that's a one dollar
one vote system and that's okay it
applies those rules to a different game
that's supposed to work according to a
different set of rules that's my issue
with it and so you go back to the
beginning capitalist and citizen it's
not capitalist hyphen citizen
its capitalist and citizen because those
are two different rules of the road for
two different spheres of our lives and
we live in this weird moment where we've
somehow convinced ourselves that the two
are co-mingled and we've jumbled them up
where in the end we're left with neither
capitalism nor democracy but a perverted
version of both so the asset management
firms the corporations that uh I'll say
that you're critiquing right
um and you agree with them on some
things you disagree with them on some
things but but generally that you're
critiquing uh they wield power uh and
use money as a weapon yes
it is uh ironic but also uh I think uh
um important to call out
you have an asset management firm and
the question becomes if money is power
or money is a weapon
is part of this almost an arms race
where you your colleagues have to go and
get as many assets as possible so that
you now have uh weapons in the fight
it's a it's a great question it's
something I struggle with
um yeah if we were starting from neutral
territory I absolutely would not be
started have started strive interesting
there's better ways to have there's
bigger problems to solve better ways to
you know have an impact to have fun and
you know find meaningful work than to do
this but we're not starting from neutral
territory and I'm a big fan I always say
you know I don't like to fight fire with
fire I prefer fighting fire with water
water tends to be more effective so so I
think that there's the fire with fire
version of this let me give you what the
fire with fire version of this looks
like is to say well you know what you're
advancing left-wing values in the
boardroom well guess what
I'm gonna raise a bunch of capital from
Republicans and bring right wing values
into the boardroom you want to push
environmental agendas and diversity
Equity inclusion well we're going to
push
fill in the blank you know pro-gun
agendas or or or funding for for you
know right to life and and pro-life
groups okay
coherent possibility
that's fighting fire with fire
I prefer to fight it with water and so
the voice we're bringing to the table is
one that says that you know what if
we're managing money for somebody who's
mandated us to manage that money with
maximizing Financial value
we say get all politics out of the
boardroom that's the fire extinguisher
okay we don't want left-wing values
right-wing values no values
Focus exclusively on products and
services for profit to maximize value
for shareholders
so
in a certain sense are we using Capital
to bring a different voice to the table
yes because it's been so weaponized in
the way that it has but I'd like to
think uh you know I mean there's nothing
there's no such thing as a pure answer
to a complicated problem but on balance
I'd like to think that what we're doing
is we're fighting fire with water and I
hope at the end of it this debate is out
of the top 10 issues that we ought to be
focused on I think it's absolutely in
the top ten today
probably pretty close to the Top If you
ask me because of this merger of state
power and corporate power but let's get
it out of the top ten and you know I
think that we can we can take the
temperature down a little bit and focus
on other problems that that need to be
solved in ways that you know this is
somehow this problem I think has has
gotten in the way of talk to me about
Netflix Netflix is an interesting uh
case where I think the public
conversation was Netflix is awesome it's
9.99 to subscribe yeah I recently looked
they now charged me 16.99 I'm not sure
how we got there but that's what they
charging inflation dude they got me uh
I'm still paying yeah
um and over the last I don't know a year
or two all of a sudden I saw a bunch of
conversation that basically could be
summed up as like Netflix went woke
right and there was different examples
there were certain things people agreed
with didn't agree with whatever but like
that was uh although small at first
became a louder uh kind of critique of
the company uh then I saw that
subscribers for the first time in their
history decreased rather than increased
in one of the quarters and of course the
people who were critiquing Netflix and
saying you're going woke and all this
stuff they basically were running like
ticker tape parades and saying like we
told you right like your business is
gonna suffer uh you know go woke go
broke and like I saw it all right
now subscriber growth has started to
re-accelerate but it seems at least from
the outside that there has been I don't
know if you call it a shift I don't know
if you call it a uh refraining of uh
kind of the politics like I I don't know
how you would even describe it you spend
more time on this than I do
um but talk a little bit as to like what
happened there yeah and how much of the
political conversation both pro and con
had an impact on the actual results of
the business in your opinion yeah so
it's a it's a good microcosm of an
example because I think it's it's a good
microcosm of a bigger theme and a bigger
prediction I have for what's happening
in American culture over the next five
years but it's pretty encouraging right
so there's a lot of Netflix's behaviors
over the course of the last couple of
years that you know I might be critical
of the content and programming and
obsession with skin deep attributes or
whatever but when Bush came to shove
they had a disastrous quarterly earnings
report where subscriber growth was down
revenues down profitabilities was down
that was you know I believe earlier this
year after which
Netflix restated its cultural document
they put seeking Excellence that was at
the top of the cultural document you'll
know this is a word that means a lot to
me we we it's strive to talk about
Excellence capitalism rather than
stakeholder capitalism The Motto the
companies invest in excellence the
second book in the subject header ends
with the path back to Excellence talk
about American national identity so so
when I with that that stood out to me
they added the word excellence back to
the top of their cultural document and
they had a clear message to their
employees and this was after the whole
employee walk out after the Dave
Chappelle special that they hosted on
some of the trans transphobia
allegations or whatever the Netflix and
and Dave Chappelle face when the deaths
are settled on that you know they said
all right look we're going to put
artistic Merit first that's what we do
deliver high quality content and that's
going to require working on a diverse
range of projects and if you're assigned
to work on a project
where you have a problem with that
project
then you can probably find a different
company to work at because that's the
kind of company Netflix is going to be
going forward
I thought it was powerful I mean this is
in the heart of Hollywood a company that
themselves I think had been guilty of
some of the same sins you know I think
there was a whole controversy about
firing people for using the wrong words
or whatever
but taking an affirmative stand to say
that you know what we are going to
prioritize Excellence at the top of our
cultural document our statement of
culture of who we are and so much so the
employees the activist employees are
going to whine about you know working on
a project that doesn't align with their
politics say you know what you can show
yourself the door and close the door on
your way out if that's the kind of place
you want to work Netflix isn't the place
for you
that was powerful and you know is is it
causally related to the fact that they
actually just had a really successful
you know even Rebound in their
subscribers I don't know but I don't but
it did have nothing to do with it
probably not you know I think that this
I think these things are powerful hard
to quantify but important in customers
who want to come back and actually see
high quality content without being
preached to at every step of the way now
why does it's a microcosm
I think it's interesting if you look at
what catalyzed that change of heart
it was undoubtedly
a form of economic hardship you know you
lose money it wakes you up and I think
that a lot of this virtue signaling that
we've seen from Corporate America in the
last couple of years
is totally the product of excess
it's actually you know people get mad
when I make this analogy in my in my
first book but so I got my first job in
New York City on the eve of the 2008
financial crisis and I just think that's
the the Big Bang the origin story for
this whole explosion of wokism in in
contemporary culture and Corporate
America I think the 2008 financial
crisis plays a pretty good pretty good
role for the start of that modern origin
story but I got my job in 2007 and I had
done an internship in a you know over
the top uh Financial firm called
amaranth in the summer of 2005.
and and so to me the analogy I draw is
the cultural excesses of Wall Street or
whatever
strip clubs throwing little people off
boats you know the kinds of stuff that
Wolf of Wall Street stuff right cultural
excess
the social virtue signaling are the
strippers and Little People tossing
parties of the pre-2008 era it's just a
different form of excess that you have
money raining from on high like Mana
from Heaven printed by the Federal
Reserve for the course of the last 14
years that have allowed an entire
culture to ski on artificial snow
forgetting what it was like to ski on
the real thing and that culture of
excess created this new moral sanctimony
that in many ways
caused organizations like Netflix but
other companies like them to forget
about the essence of who they were and
it took hardship to be able to remind
them that okay I don't get to indulge in
that excess forever strip clubs Little
People tossing or virtue signal woke
virtue signaling whatever it might be
I've put all of those in more or less
the same category is it a religion
actually there's there's a chapter in my
my first book I said wokeness is like a
religion actually wokeness is literally
a religions in a legal sense it is
um yeah I think it meets the legal
definition of what counts as a religion
and you know I mean a couple chapters
making the legal argument for it but but
the interesting thing is I think
hardship can be a wake-up call out of
that cult you know my definition occult
is in some ways a religion that has not
yet withstood the test of time so if
this is a religion I think we'd be
better calling it a cult because it has
not yet withstood the test of time but
the interesting thing is economic
hardship is a great way to wake you up
out of the whatever cult you're
professing allegiance to and you know I
think that in some ways we're about to
enter a really tough time economically
in our country this is a you know
prediction I made in my next book
and by the way I had finished writing
this book
um you know before even in much of this
year had had played out right so you
know made this prediction we've already
seen it play out over the course of this
year with inflation Rising interest
rates the economic hardship possible
recession I think that's I think we're
in for harder times to come there's a
longer story for another day but unlike
1980s early 1980s style inflation
busting with raising interest rates well
that was when we're doing against the
backdrop of Reagan's deregulatory tax
lowering policies today we're raising
rates against the backdrop of Biden
economic policies that actually create a
potential one-two punch I think we're
gonna be in for an air of a few years of
economic hardship but I think that could
actually be a good thing for our culture
if we remind ourselves you know hardship
is not the same thing as victimhood as I
often say what does that mean is just
like Netflix you need a wake-up call at
quarterly earnings report that's a
disaster before you put Excellence back
at the top of your cultural document as
a company I think the same thing might
be true for our entire economy for our
entire country is it might take us to a
chance of actually going through a
period of economic hardship against the
backdrop of not only inflation But
Rising rates reminding ourselves that
Mana does not fall like heaven from free
from on high but reminding ourselves
where actual value creation may come
from from industriousness productivity
of creating goods and services that make
people's lives better that's hard work
it's different than an economy that's
that's effectively fueled by that
artificial snow that could actually
strengthen and create a stronger economy
and a stronger culture on the back of it
but I think the path from the victimhood
narratives that we wallow in today
ironically which is a product of
actually a period of excess we wallow in
these victimhood narratives not because
we've had it so hard for that last 10
years but because we haven't had it hard
enough the path from victimhood back to
Excellence ironically is going to run
through a period of hardship that's what
I see coming in the next couple of years
but I also think that could be that
could be
you know one version of the story at
least is good for our culture and come
out as a stronger Nation on the other
side of it that's what the many rises in
the many Falls of Rome look like
hopefully this won't be the last fall of
that American experiment but we still
have you know a couple a couple Rises
still left in us and if we don't then
then maybe we are in the beginning of
that National decline yeah I originally
had a conversation with uh Harvard
Professor uh ranjay gulati and uh he's
done a bunch of study talked to hundreds
of companies about purpose and so when
you first hear that you think uh ESG
versus signaling like all his own okay
all right so that's not what purpose is
fundamental to a company so that's his
point it is not that stuff it is the
most ambitious Mission attracts the best
talent period the yeah just just if you
have a super ambitious Mission people
want to work on hard problems people
want to work on things that are going to
be big and are going to work and do all
this stuff if you have a very clear
purpose
going back to the Netflix example
coinbase many of these companies who
have come out and said this is what we
stand for there are other things that
are important in the world but they are
not important to us and this is if you
work at our company this is what we are
focused on that Clarity attracts a
certain type of employee it attracts a
certain type of business partner it
attracts a certain Clarity in action of
what we will focus on what we won't
focus on so he goes through all these
things and I found the conversation
fascinating because
that terminology that uh uh entire
mechanism all the stuff
has almost been co-opted to some degree
and polled where to your point the
purpose of companies may not be to
maximize shareholder value the purpose
of a company may be to essentially
pursue political or social issues or do
all this other stuff
and he's able to just strip it away and
say listen purpose of the business and
the clarity and the ambition of it is
maybe one of the most important things
in order to make sure that you sustain
for very long periods of time and you
continue to succeed regardless of
management changes Market changes
competitive changes product changes or
anything else
and so it feels like you and him are
saying very similar things absolutely
I'm a big believer in purpose and
Mission orientation okay I don't
question even even think about strive
right we don't second-guess a company's
true State admission Disney's stated
mission is to be the world's Premier
Entertainment Company okay
what does that have to do with
transgender education in Florida Public
Schools right they will disguise that
say this about purpose and being
purposeful interaction how does that
relate to providing high quality
entertainment for children and their
families I mean this is a good worthy
question to ask so I think this this
idea of purpose and mission mission
comes first you want to be a great Solar
Company great be a great Solar Company a
great Coal Company be a great Coal
Company that's different from telling
the coal company that has to be a Solar
Company and so I think that mission
orientation comes first and when all of
this discussion we have about diversity
your Equity or inclusion or whatever my
view is in order to pursue your mission
there are certain kinds of diversity
You're Gonna Want
you're going to need
there's going to be certain kinds of
diversity you're not going to want
you're not going to need so let's say
you're running a steakhouse okay and
your mission is to serve excellent high
quality good tasting steak that Delights
your customers
you probably don't want even the
ever-prized diversity of thought
when it comes to viewpoints on whether
it is morally reprehensible to kill
animals for culinary pleasure
one of the main reasons I would not make
for a good employee at a steakhouse I'm
a vegetarian for that reason I don't I
don't believe in killing animals for
culinary pleasure for health reasons if
it's necessary for human health
absolutely short of that for culinary
pleasure I'd rather not do it I would
not make for a good employee at a
steakhouse because I would not be
Mission aligned with the purpose of that
organization
and that's okay that means that
different organizations are going to
take diverse approaches to diversity
itself
right diversity or other parameters that
contribute to the success of a mission
have to fall out of the mission and what
we've seen happen in the ESG Revolution
is that one common set of centralized
purpose or missions
have supplanted and diluted the true
truly diverse missions that different
companies and different institutions
actually have so right now why is there
a common why are there three letter
acronyms ESG or Dei that should govern
what a technology company does versus
what an energy company does versus what
a fast food company does versus what a
non-profit does or a university does why
do all of them have the same purpose
rather than each being Guided by their
own unique purpose That's What I Call
institutional pluralism institutional
pluralism is the heart of American
pluralism and yet what we've done in the
name of purpose right and so I actually
wrote an op-ed in the Wall Street
Journal it's it's basically like the
place that I love the Wall Street
Journal by the way because like
something about my way of presenting
ideas jazz or the way they present ideas
so that's basically the only place I
publish anymore but do it pretty
frequently but one of mine earlier this
year was on
responding to Larry Fink's annual letter
to CEOs where he says companies need to
be guided by purpose it in that same
letter says that we want to see from you
how you're complying with the standards
of the sustainability Accounting
Standards Board we want to understand
what your climate action 100 goals are
what your climate action pledges are
what your path to Net Zero by 2050 is we
need to see this information
you can't say both those things at once
either you believe each company has its
own purpose or you believe that your
purpose is more important than their
purpose and all institutions should
pursue your purpose instead but you
can't say both at the same time and yet
that's the ESG double speak because in
the name of purpose and Mission what
they're really saying is that our
mission and purpose is more important
than yours and that's why you need to
follow it or else and we're going to use
our Capital as a weapon to make sure you
do
when you see this playing out in the
market
it feels like employees
don't really have a say at many of these
companies the executives are playing a
game of almost like a Virtual Tennis
right with these Asset Management firms
what do The Regulators think how do they
kind of play into this are they like oh
the people with a lot of money like uh
they're cool to kind of run around and
do whatever they want are there rules
against this stuff or they're not rules
against it like I kind of almost think
about uh we usually think of two Market
participants but there is a third yeah
there's a third yeah I mean this episode
is brought to you by eight sleep good
sleep is a game changer and the eight
sleep pod is the best sleep machine I
sleep on it every single night a great
night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod 3 you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees Fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees Fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
in eat sleep you can go to eatsleep.com
pump today to go ahead and get 150 off
your order eightsleep.com pump not only
do I sleep on it every night it
literally changed my life and I begged
the founder so let me invest in the
company eight sleep.com go get yourself
an eight sleep pod and get a better
night of sleep so like I can you know I
have my views on this I mean I think
there's an interplay between what the
regulators and the regulated sometimes
you worry about you you wonder who's
regulating who actually um I think if
you look at what some of these new SEC
rules are that are coming down the pike
that's in some ways just borrowing
exactly from the ESG textbook but
codifying it in law and there it's all
one giant circular reference too they're
saying well we need these added ESG
disclosures and put them in rule because
that's what the investors are demanding
well those investors are themselves
behaving like Regulators in the way they
behave you know the black rocks of the
world so so I think that there's a
there's a discursive relationship
between the two but I look at it a
little bit differently
I think that
you can be brought up employees I think
that there's something deeper going on
here okay in our moment in American
history modern Western history
I think the defining
social political and cultural divide
is not between
left and right
black and white or even rich and poor
okay
it is between the managerial class
and the everyday citizen there's an
everyday citizen in every organization
made an employee a stockholder a voter
in government
that everyday individual agent versus
this horizontal managerial class the
professional bureaucracy the people
whose staff that 80 person Department
that decides how BlackRock votes its
shares the middle manager at the
three-letter alphabet soup in the
federal government that isn't
politically accountable and is hired for
life under Civil Service rules cannot be
fired the person who's serving on it is
a professional director a renter
director or rent a CFO hopping around
seats in Corporate America in the
executive ranks this is the rise of this
managerial class this guy Michael Lind
actually the center left guy wrote about
this you know a little bit ago I have a
chapter in in my last book called The
Rise of the managerial class
the bureaucratization of decision making
and the people who staff those
bureaucracies I think they are crushing
the will of the everyday citizens who
these institutions were supposed to
represent
be at a university be it a philanthropy
be it a non-profit be it a company or
beat our government
that's the real distinction that matters
so when you talk about the regulator
the regulator and the regulated are
basically today more or less run by
members of that managerial class the
professional bureaucratized technocratic
green hat wearing
Square suit monitor they're all kind of
regular the hall monitor exactly
and the hall monitor in in America in
the modern West for the last
10 years or so the hall monitor is
running the show and I think that that's
the we sort of mixed this up by trying
to retrofit this into a left wing versus
a right-wing debate you're missing the
point it's the managerial class versus
the everyday citizen why do the
managerial class become the managerial
class and I always they couldn't be
creators themselves okay so this is an
interesting uh kind of
path to get there we have the benefit of
hindsight now is it the education system
is it all the wealthy families of
America came together and told their
kids hey we're going to put you in these
places of the managerial class so I'm
going to resist both of those okay for a
second because
I think I think this this distinction
I'm drawing does not map neatly onto the
people with money or even the people
with education so like this is where
some of the populist right frustrates me
at times I I'm very sympathetic to
actually people who identify with
themselves as everyday citizens being on
the populist right it's a sole separate
discussion we can have for another day
but the the slogans of the people who
lead that movement when they talk about
the elites
I think it's too sloppy it's too low
resolution so even if you just like
double click on one institution let's
take the university okay modern liberal
arts university whatever take Harvard or
Yale my alma Motors or whatever Elite
institutions
the students are Elites
the professors are Elites the associate
Deans are Elites but I'm making a
different point I'm saying that that
Institution
is about
educating
the constituents of that
institution the students and the
creative minds who are pushing the
frontiers of knowledge like the zany
professors neither of those are strictly
speaking in in my definition of the
managerial class as applied to the
university members of the managerial
class but the members of the managerial
class are the cancerous proliferation of
associate Deans and administrators at
universities I mean at Michigan State
you know the the growth in the number of
Dei officials diversity Equity inclusion
officers outpaces the growth in
professors at that University
so so all of them are Elites in some
sense but I'm not even I'm not even
talking about left or right or rich or
poor or drawing all those distinctions
I'm literally talking about the people
who didn't have the creativity of mind
to be a professor but didn't have the
humility to actually know that there
shouldn't be exercising power then in a
university either but it's the
Confluence of
absence of creativity to sufficient to
be a Creator but with a power hungriness
combined with insecurity that still
wants you to be able to exercise control
those are the features of a member of
the managerial class it's a feature of
the manager class of somebody who staffs
the alphabet soup from the FTC to FDA to
SCC to FBI to pick your favorite TSA
that's what characterizes I think a lot
of the Civil Service class in this
country the Civil serve an unfireable
civil servant class in the federal
government bureaucracy it's what
characterizes a lot of middle management
in Corporate America it's what
characterizes the cancerous
proliferation of the associate Deans in
the modern University the same people
get the ambassadorships that are that
are sort of mid-level donors to a
campaign and get to be sent off to be
the ambassador to Lithuania or whatever
you see in the in the military
increasingly in the United States too
the rise of a managerial class that
didn't really rise the ranks as a
soldier nor actually had the vision to
be an outsider that was a general that
thought about things differently but
were sort of this Halfway House in
between and I just look at one
institution after another people serve
on some God forsaken non-profits board
that gets together to have a boondoggle
four times a year because they could
care less about the mission but they
will be able to say to their friends at
the country club that I'm on the board
of a non-profit as though we didn't have
to fill in the blank about what
non-profit it was it doesn't matter
points there on the board right and if
they're not on that board they're gonna
make sure they get another one that's
what they call their board card I I get
sick of it when I hear people in
Corporate America or in the non-profit
World talk about their board card
of course the card of boards they're on
that their board card is full or that
they have an extra slot like they have
to fill it it's about them and their
exercise of power
but there's a sort of you kind of the
everyday I think there's kind of three
camps here right and this maybe make a
lot of people uncomfortable to you know
characterize this maybe there's elitist
maybe it is elitist I could care less
maybe but I'm just telling you how I how
I see it you have everyday citizens
you got the managerial class and then
you got the third class who were neither
everyday citizens ordinary everyday
citizens nor members of the managerial
class but the creators okay
what we have right now going on is a tug
of war between the three and and both
the everyday Citizen and the creators
are losing and the managerial class is
winning
and that applies whether you're looking
at the private sector or the non-profit
sector the for-profit sector or
government the managerial class is
winning and I think that that's what's
fueling the Fanning the Flames of global
populism both left-wing and right-wing
populism they'll Point each other and
think they're different they're not so
different from each other I think what
they're hungry for is Reviving that
voice of the citizen and the creators
have more or less been been muzzled and
that's kind of the current state of
affairs that you know once you see that
problem clearly it becomes pretty clear
what you need to do but I think the
first step is we haven't really seen
that problem with Clarity put into
relief in its own right because we have
these blinders on that have taught us to
see this through Republican or
Democratic struggles or black versus
white or intersectional woke narratives
of invisible power struggles nah that's
all missing the point it's the
managerial class the everyday Citizen
and the creators we need creators who
serve the everyday citizens and the
manager class are intermediating that at
best without exercising independent
power of their own that's the right
ordering of Affairs in an American
society we've talked a lot about the
insular critiques and and uh of the
American economy of of society uh but
also there are external components to
the American experiment China probably
is the biggest one uh that people talk
about and when it comes to China it
feels like uh there is also this tug of
war it feels like there are countries uh
who seem to align with China there are
countries who seem not to align with uh
China but the countries are really uh
just the like the warm-up game because
it seems like the companies are actually
the ones who are uh maybe in the most uh
sympathetic view you could say caught in
the crossfire in the most uh critical
view You could argue that they are the
ones who are actually doing the shooting
and
it is not clear to me why some companies
are welcome
some companies are uh kicked out
and why so many companies in the United
States seem so focused on appeasing
China yeah sometimes at the detriment to
Americans American society or the
economics of their p l and their balance
sheet so so this is the defining threat
to the future of American existence I
think is the way in which China defeats
the United States not militarily from
the outside but from within the 500 year
game the 500 year game and So speaking
of going hundreds of years back to learn
the lesson so I'll draw an analogy to
the Trojan War okay
Greece was never going to defeat Troy
militarily the walls of Troy were too
strong
what they realized though is that there
was the Trojan Horse
that literally the church literally that
literally Troy could not resist the
beautiful horse the gift of that Trojan
Horse they offered that as a peace
offering
and what happened
they loaded their they loaded their
infantry within and they burned Troy
from the inside out okay that's what
happened that's how the battle of Troy
ended
that's what China is recognized to the
United States
global capitalism
is the gift we could not resist it was
the sweet fruit fruit whose taste we
could not resist
that is the gift they offered us in
return to use that as a vehicle
for advancing their agendas not
militarily from the outside in through
Force but from the inside out through
actually infecting our system from
within
that sounds conspiratorial I'll just lay
it out exactly how it works okay let's
do it we tell ourselves right we live in
this system of global free market
capitalism okay well it doesn't work if
other actors in that system are playing
a mercantilist game of State directed
capitalism so what China does they
realize they have a big growth area for
for most companies most companies that
need growth the place where they get
that growth is by going to China okay
China's the biggest growth area for our
business or whatever fill in the blank
that's what you can hear from from half
of America's public companies
what China does though is they build a
great wall a great Chinese wall that
prevents you from entering the Chinese
market if you criticize the CCP if you
apply any constraints on what Chinese
companies are or aren't able to do you
have a great Chinese wall that prevents
you from entering the Chinese market
but if you criticize the United States
or you apply some of those constraints
that you don't apply in China to your
American counterparts they will roll out
the red carpet
and that is how you get to the farcical
world in which
Chevron and Exxon have their large
shareholders like BlackRock imposing ESG
constraints scope 3 emissions caps
emissions reduction targets by 2050 to
exons and chevron's business
without saying a peep while they're also
a large shareholder of petrochina that
operates according to none of those ESG
constraints I don't know why because if
you apply those ESG constraints to a
Chinese company the CCP is going to tell
you you know what again you can show
yourself out and close the door on your
way out you can't do business here
it's how you get to a place where Disney
okay will wax eloquent about transgender
education of first graders in the State
of Florida or says it can't shoot a film
in the state of in Georgia if if they
pass some kind of new anti-abortion
statute or whatever Disney will be
proudly stand on the right side of
History over here while they literally
go to
shenzhang The Ground Zero starting point
of the uyghur human rights crisis where
there are over 1 million religious
minorities enslaved in concentration
camps a lot of people don't know this
subject to forced sterilization
communist indoctrination and worse
Disney doesn't say a peep as they film
Mulan there
until they muster up the courage at the
very end of the movie you could see in
the credits to the film today where they
said we thank the local authorities for
allowing us the privilege of filming
here the very local authorities that are
responsible for some of the worst human
rights atrocities committed by a major
Nation since the Third Reich of Germany
that's how you get to that asymmetry
and what does that do
it creates a false moral equivalence
between the United States and China it
morally legitimizes China's behaviors
relative to those of the United States
because when the new corporations
multinational corporations headquartered
in America become the new international
Arbiters of moral Justice the people who
are always known to criticize Injustice
Nike the NBA critiquing systemic racism
and white supremacy in the United States
not saying a peep about actual human
rights atrocities in China you know Nike
complaining about slave labor 250 years
ago in this country without actually
doing a thing to reduce its own Reliance
on slave labor today that produces 250
sneakers that they sell the black kids
in the inner city who can't afford to
buy books for school I mean this is a
two-sided game that's laughable if it
weren't for the fact that it was
actually a product of China's strategy
and having this product of China's
strategy listen to Xi Jinping when he's
pressed say by the UN on the weaker
human rights crisis the first thing he
often says is that black lives matter
shows that the United States is no
better
his top Diplomat Yang jiaichi came to
Alaska about a year and a half ago
lectures are Secretary of State Tony
blinken for 15 minutes in his opening
statement this guy from China says what
is it uh I want to see the United States
stop slaughtering is his word
slaughtering black Americans and that
China wants to see the U.S do better on
human rights
this would be laughable
if it weren't for the fact that our own
corporations lend implicit credibility
to those claims by regularly critiquing
Injustice on the s-prong of the ESG
movement in the United States without
saying a peep in China in fact when they
go to China if the CCP says jump the
number one question they ask is how high
and that erodes
our number one geopolitical asset of all
and I'm sorry that is not our nuclear
Arsenal it is our moral standing on the
global stage creating this false
equivalence between Chinese nihilism and
American idealism thank you LeBron James
thank you Nike thank you Disney thank
you Airbnb that's the net effect that it
has and I think that that is how
this version of Greece burning Troy from
within that is how you get to a place
where Airbnb gets to post a nice little
neat black Square on its Instagram
account and says that black lives matter
and they compensate their Executives
according to social social and
environmental goals yet
every unit of data they gain from a user
even the private messages exchanged
between a host and actually a person
who's staying at a host's house or
information that's available to the CCP
as a condition for airbnb's ability to
do business in China but a lot of people
didn't know that no explain that yeah I
mean the Wall Street Journal reporting
on this from a year or two ago I mean
it's staggering stuff okay I mean like
Nate blacharchik he was a couple years
ahead of me at Harvard or whatever I
don't think I knew the guy but his quote
at the end of this I mean I I knew of
him staggering we're not here to promote
American values that's what he says
behind closed doors to their head of
privacy who resigned when when the
company didn't do anything to change
this China's condition for Airbnb doing
business in China
is that they turn over data from
American users geolocational data I mean
the private messages like emails between
a host and someone who's renting on the
platform those are messages that you can
bet if the CCP wants to look at it it's
available to them because that was the
ticket for entry that's the price for
entering the great Chinese wall to cross
the Chinese wall that's your ticket fee
if you're a BNB to go after the Chinese
market and what does China want to do
with stuff like that well I'm not sure
they know exactly what they want to do
right they're in a data collection game
part of knowing data is you don't
necessarily know exactly what you're
going to use until you see what you see
what you find but it's a long run game
of gaining a competitive strategic
Advantage because they know we couldn't
resist the sweet gift the Sweet Taste of
global capitalism that's our Trojan
Horse when they're not actually playing
by those same rules they're playing
mercantilist capitalism but giving us
the Trojan Horse that makes it look like
we're all playing in the same game of
global actual capitalism and so no now
companies now you could say my view is
that companies should just focus on
their products and services maximize
profits well wouldn't they be doing this
in China because this is actually their
cost benefit analysis that tells them
that's what they're going to do maybe
almost certainly Yes actually
but they wouldn't come out of it
smelling like a rose and the public
would be able to it's like it's like
tampering with the smoke detector at the
at the urinal on the airplane Okay the
reason you don't tamper with the smoke
detector is there's a system that's
designed to check this Behavior users
would not trust Airbnb quite as much if
it didn't pretend to be a Silicon Valley
Goody Two Shoe ESG compliant Dei
promoting company that puts in these
posts in these posts a neat little black
Square on its Instagram account which
you're supposed to do after George Floyd
dies
this is a game is it's a decoy it's a
tripwire it's messing with the smoke
detector that otherwise would have had
the system work itself out except for
the consumer duping aspect of it now
we're in the worst of all worlds or
they're actually subsidizing human
rights atrocities selling you and your
privacy down the river as a condition
for them doing business in China named
liturgic and the other co-founders of
Airbnb get to be billionaires in the
back of it but leaving the everyday
consumer here believing that they're
looking after their societal interests
when in fact it was all bogus in the
two-faced behavior that we're seeing
between how they actually behave in
China versus how they behave here I
think it's I think it borders on fraud I
think it is it is a direct Product of
China calling our Bluff our own
addiction to what we thought of as
capitalism they weaponized back against
us to actually Advance the agenda that
was you're seeing XI jinping's True
Colors now show the Communist and
indicatorial agenda using the the
temporary and it was I think a fleeting
engagement in playing the rules of
global capitalism to really just create
the vectors that I think plant the seeds
from from our demise from within and I
know that sounds dramatic and over Rock
but I think if you just look at if you
just look at I mean this is this is not
a conspiracy theory it's a conspiracy
reality hiding in plain sight and I
think the later we wake up to it and the
later we do something about it the more
we're heading towards an inevitable uh
you know an inevitable shift in the
balance of global power between the
United States and China
do you guys go short companies or are
you only not yet yeah I mean I mean so
so strong I mean back in my old career
so my first job is my third career um I
could say it's my fourth career I guess
my first group was as a hedge fund uh
person so I was a partner in a hedge
fund did that from 2007 to 2014. I spent
three of those years at the same time in
law school that's when I kind of got my
law degree on the side that was just for
fun but I was a biotech investor you
know foremost from 2007 to 2014. that
was long short so so I lived in that
world I I stepped down from that job to
start the biotech company that I led so
I did that for seven years from 2014 to
2021 stepped down to then you know do
the do the author thing do the writer
writing and uh and speaking and thought
leadership thing and I really enjoyed
that it did that for two years but then
got back to starting this company what
you're almost doing is you're putting a
social a social geopolitical uh ethical
ethos whatever you're going to call it
kind of viewpoint or vector on top of it
and you're basically saying uh there is
a argument that if everyone was playing
with perfect information they knew all
these things about these companies
they're doing or whatever then you could
actually get an edge in investing in the
market because that would have an impact
on how these companies perform you know
I would say that's a couple things about
that I mean I think that it's not clear
that just because Airbnb does this it's
going to be a less successful company it
might be a more successful company so
I'm not sure that shorting that just
because you don't like it just because
you don't need the company behaves if
the users knew it but if the users knew
it right that's what I'm saying it's a
perfect set if it's a perfect
information I'll give you another this
is just to sort of go on a side tangent
here but but I'll give you another area
where where something like this might be
more even you know on the money here
so are you familiar with the notion of
Chinese tech stocks that trade on the
New York Stock Exchange not actually
being stocks is this something these are
the what is it called uh variable
interest entities yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so this is the part that shocks me
right you think about like The
Regulators you know investor protection
and all that you'll hear okay well let's
talk about let's talk about investor
protection here
so China's about to I mean I think in
the coming years about to invade Taiwan
I wrote about this you know last couple
weeks that's something we should
probably talk about but I think that's
one of the Unseen investment risk
underappreciated investment risks
probably coming sometime in the next
half decade okay
anyway what are one of the risks that we
might be able to think are foreseeable
risks that's hiding in plain sight
well most people who invest in Alibaba
for good reason the ticker is Baba after
all think that they own a share of
Alibaba or most people that invest in
tencent think that they own a share of
tencent
here's the bad news
you don't actually own a share of
tencent or Alibaba if you're an American
investor that thinks you're buying
tencent or Alibaba on the New York Stock
Exchange why is that because there's a
Chinese law that says that for certain
sectors including the tech sector you
can't be a foreign owner of a Chinese
company it doesn't work can't be a
Chinese non-chinese National who owns
that company
so what did what did a bunch of these
financial institutions in the US do they
created what are called uh these
variable interest entities what's that
it's a Cayman shell company
that has a contract with Alibaba or with
tencent to receive a stream of profits
and that came in Shell company is what
masquerades as a share of Alibaba or
tencent on the on the stock exchange or
wherever else that investors can
actually buy
the problem is that contract is itself
invalid is invalid under Chinese law
because there's a different provision of
Chinese law that says that any contract
written to sidestep a legal prohibition
is itself invalid and how do we know
that it's actually invalid Chinese
courts have held in certain cases well
that's been litigated that those con
those contracts are invalid including by
the way even in the case of Alibaba
where Yahoo actually this is a big funny
funny enough case where because you can
do this kind of thing in China Jack ma
says that you know what the most
valuable part of alibaba's business or
one of the most valuable Parts is alipay
let me just take it out and call it and
financial and put that under 100 owned
company that I own 100 of well Yahoo was
a shareholder in Alibaba and didn't like
that very much so they tried to sue in
which case the Chinese courts actually
say well you don't actually have an
ability to sue because your whole
entitlement to owning a share in Alibaba
was itself illegal under Chinese law so
already been already been demonstrated
how farcical this is and by the way Jack
ma almost got to take ant financially
again but U.S because us investors were
still going to eat that up
notwithstanding that having happened oh
crazy if you think about it but when
China invades Taiwan and the U.S takes
steps towards you know
retaliating in some way economically or
otherwise an easy thing for China to be
able to do
is to say that you know the one to two
trillion dollars of market
capitalization of Chinese stocks that
trade on your exchanges that are really
just variable interest entities
you know I know we haven't enforced that
very much but we're just going to tell
you that
that's wiped out that's illegal under
Chinese law and those investors are left
holding worthless instruments
uh you might say that we'd go to the WTO
and say that hey World Trade
Organization you admitted China aren't
they aren't they foul playing here and
actually they would say well actually
Chinese law has been pretty clear for a
long time so under Chinese law that was
an invalid contract all the way along I
believe the WTO is likely to side with
China on that that's an investment risk
that's a geopolitical view an
underappreciated risk an
underappreciated risk because of
the let's just say the beholden the ways
in which these financial institutions
like BlackRock and others are beholden
China you know I think that if they warn
investors about this risk explicitly I
don't think the CCP would like that very
much if the CCP doesn't like that very
much then they're going to say that you
can't be an asset manager in China you
have an under undereducated investing
public does that create opportunities
for risk mitigation for protection
Etc I I think it does I think it can but
you know my view is if you want to be an
active fund manager generating Alpha is
a really hard thing to do I spent my
first part of my career uh you know
having some success as a biotech
investor you know generating Alpha is
hard so so I'm a big skeptic of of just
sort of armchair quarterbacking and
Alpha thesis but that's why you know
this business is is almost a a very
different business from running a hedge
fund it's really running a company that
offers a financial product that just
offers beta exposure to the market but
we're focusing more on the voice and
vote
and you know in the future we might have
actively managed products as well that's
something we're contemplating for next
year but you know at that time that
would be the case where we would sort of
take advantage of the marketing
efficiencies but for now we're just
focusing on voice and vote to get off
the ground if China invaded Taiwan what
do you think the US would do
great question
um so
so we I mean I have a lot of views on
this
um I think it's I got a lot of time I
think it's pretty I think it's a pretty
important topic that people are are way
undereducated about so once Nancy Pelosi
visited and nothing happened I think
people like ah it's not going to happen
yeah well I don't know right like I
think that's kind of the sentiment like
way underage so yeah forget online uh
yeah I mean
that's my that's what you pay for online
yeah that's my uh my read let's do a
little like a brief history lesson here
all right so how does Taiwan get outside
of China yeah so it was a brief history
lesson just because history teaches us a
lot they review the present a little bit
differently if you have at least some
historical context so you know like the
Qing Dynasty the Ming Dynasty the the
end of the Chinese Empire that was kind
of you know pre-World War One 1910s
early 1910s 1912 that's kind of what's
going on in China now Sun yat sen is
this guy who actually goes and camps out
in Singapore so think about Taiwan is
outside China I want to come back to
that Singapore's even further away sun
yatsen goes all the way down to then
critique actually the Empire and sort of
sends a bunch of missives that basically
caused the Empire itself to come
crumbling down now what happens in the
wake is you kind of have two parties you
have the the Chinese Communist party and
you have the the Chinese nationalist
party and there's a power struggle for
who actually holds the keys to power and
there's this Chinese Civil War that
starts you know I'm getting the I mean
I'm I you know I'm gonna refresh myself
before this but let's call it 1920s you
know thereabouts I'm gonna give this
about right
um post World War One Chinese civil war
between the two factions
that Civil War continues till about like
the beginning of 1937 when they put that
on pause when Japan actually makes its
Invasion on China so people Europeans
think about World War II is actually
beginning in 1939 well the Japan China
theater actually begins starts to begin
the clock on World War II a little bit
earlier around 1937 they put the Civil
War on pause and they said we're going
to be united front against fighting
against Japan but then after World War
II ends you know famously when you go to
the story of World War II ends 1945 they
go back to warring factions and then
they go for four more years of Civil War
and shanghai-shek who Shanghai who
basically leads the Nationalist faction
loses out to Mao Zedong who is the
leader of the Communist Chinese party so
Chiang Kai-shek flees to Taiwan but his
objective in fling to Taiwan wasn't to
sort of set up a new nation a new
country there but to sort of set up a
campground or sort of a holding pattern
for planning his retake over of China
mainland China because they were in a
power struggle remember for who
controlled China here yours Game of
Thrones drones or you wrote Game of
Thrones or was that a thing I haven't
watched it but uh I mean whatever I was
it was like the equivalent of like
Dragon Stone as like a waiting Stone
Island if any for any any viewer who's
familiar with that but whatever it's a
waiting house for then taking over so if
China views this as unfinished business
in its Civil War right it was a
dissident camp this is unfinished
business that they need to tie up now
Taiwan does something interesting Chiang
Kai-shek actually in this a number of
interesting Dynamics in Taiwan that
people forget about too is that there
was actually an indigenous Taiwanese
population so most of Taiwan and the
Taiwanese party that Chiang Kai-shek
actually led the Nationalist party that
came over to Taiwan they were actually
Chinese people that sort of took control
of this island so there's a whole
separate dynamic in Taiwan too between
the native Taiwanese and between the uh
you know the native Taiwanese in the
Chinese made a nationalist party that
came over but nonetheless you know he
sets an agenda rules with an Iron Fist
of his own decides to place his bets on
the semiconductor industry so that's
where we want to be a leader
turns out that becomes a really
important leadership because it's a
really good bet that pays off pretty
well Taiwan then becomes the world's
leading Fountainhead for producing
semiconductors starting with the biggest
of those companies tsmc which
manufactures basically a majority of the
world's leading Edge semiconductors so
like the way semiconductors are
basically the chips that power our
iPhones are are you know TVs our
computers even the refrigerators that
probably kept this bottle of water cold
before we're drinking it powered by
semiconductors and the way a
semiconductor works is that
depends on how much detail you want to
get into here but you can pack more onto
a chip the smaller the transistor is and
so in the United States we make like you
know 10 to 20 nanometer sort of
transistor semiconductors that's kind of
the most advanced we've gotten to today
you know in in Taiwan tsmc gets to
single digit nanometers seven meters
maybe even sub seven nanometers uh
semiconductors with where you're talking
about the width of the transistor which
means you can fit more transistors on a
chip which in turn gives it a lot more
power so that's what we call Leading
Edge semiconductors Taiwan is like the
leading Island for producing these
semiconductors for the global supply
chain globally including you know Apple
relying heavily all the major companies
you'd know relying for Leading Edge
semiconductors from Taiwan and even the
best military equipment relies on more
advanced semiconductors so Taiwan
becomes this becomes this leader now
China still has this piece of unfinished
business but something's happened in the
meantime both China and the US the
economies as we know it our modern way
of life comes to depend on the
semiconductors produced in Taiwan so
China adopts this industrial policy you
know pouring a bunch of money into the
semiconductor industry with mixed
results and it's it's it's still to me
as you know somewhat of an observer of
this space a little bit opaque okay as
to how well China is actually doing on
this front Okay so some Reports say that
they're actually making progress on
seven nanometer semiconductors others
say that actually they've launched these
corruption investigations which is
usually a sign that something didn't
work in the CCP is they invest to get
the people who did it for corruption
they actually were just failed at doing
it so that's what China is doing
meanwhile in the United States we got
the chips act 52 billion dollars chips
Act passed here Etc we could debate the
merits of that policy but that's what's
going on but what's actually
economically at stake for the invasion
of Taiwan is control of that
semiconductor supply chain
it's actually related to the theme of
one of the more recent funds that we
launched uh strive actually one of our
most recent funds is is a fund called
Shock s-h-o-c preparing for the shock to
the Global Financial system if and when
China does make its move to Annex Taiwan
because if China makes that move to
Annex Taiwan what people in the United
States Miss is that if China controls
the global semiconductor supply chain
what that means is that we may lack
access American companies may like
access to produce the very goods that we
rely on for a modern way of life that's
going to be a shock to the system most
of the market is going to probably react
very poorly to that I think that's not a
controversial thing to say but the one
potential glimmer of hope in that
scenario could be the U.S semiconductor
stocks
if those companies actually step up to
the plate and start shorting up their
domestic production capabilities
starting now which they're not ready to
do and the irony though is this kind of
relates to the earlier part of the
conversation we had is the top
shareholders of those companies
companies like BlackRock that will add
Intel to its climate-focused universe so
Intel is part of blackrock's so-called
climate focused Universe the universe of
stocks that need to focus more on
emissions caps
have underprepared and under engaged
with these companies to say a peep about
this actual risk surprisingly quiet
about it and so that's what we point out
with which August you know strive
doesn't do business in China we're not
beholden to whether China is going to be
happy with what we're saying or not but
shock is a U.S semiconductor index fund
a fund that tracks the underlying index
of U.S semiconderial companies where we
tell those companies
focusing on Long Run value this is a
risk and opportunity to prepare ahead of
China's invasion of Taiwan now when and
how is China going to do it we could
debate that you know extensively have a
lot of views on that but this is
probably probably the I think it's
probably one of the biggest if not the
biggest risk factor if you ask me that
the investing public is undereducated on
is the likelihood and by the way we're
chatting at an interesting month right
now this is the month that Xi Jinping is
literally taking over his third term as
leader of the CCP Breaking the Chain of
succession
in the CCP
it's a big deal he's now going to become
as of this week actually becomes the
longest serving Chinese leader since Mao
Zedong
he wasn't going to actually go for
Taiwan and I've been saying I've said
this for a long time he wasn't going to
go for Taiwan before he took that third
term over this October because that was
a big deal did not want to take any risk
of internal instability International
backlash could be a source of
instability but now that he has that
grip on power I think that starts the
clock for when he's likely to make that
move on Taiwan and I think the Global
Financial system is undereducated and
underprepared for it precisely because
of this semiconductor issue talk a
little bit about uh the agreement
between Taiwan and China and the
independence but the independence
expires uh that's right and uh when does
that happen and how does that play into
the calculation as to if and when China
would make a move so China says what
they want to get to is a one country two
systems model like they had for Hong
Kong although that agreement itself has
has slowly dissolved right so I think
they want Taiwan to go the direction of
Hong Kong first bring it into the orbit
one country two systems but then
eventually as we're seeing with Hong
Kong dissolving that as well
I can't get into XI jinping's head but
you know I think I think those who are
scholars in the area I think point to
2049 as like kind of the drop dead date
for doing this why 2049 that's the
hundred year anniversary of when the
Chinese Civil War ended with changshai
Chiang Kai-shek fleeing to Taiwan you
know they think in these Hundred Year
time Rises I don't think he wants to get
to that hundred year anniversary without
tying up that piece of Unfinished
Business now I think there are scenarios
where it could happen much much much
sooner than that I mean there's a
Taiwanese presidential election where a
new Taiwanese president takes office in
May of 2024. there's a U.S presidential
election where there's a new U.S
president I could remind you who could
take office as soon as January 2025.
it's entirely possible Xi Jinping
doesn't want to take either of those
risks right and now he's passed his
you know passed his date of taking that
third term over so I think the clock is
actively ticking and this is a big risk
factor so I mean what can do as an asset
manager okay you offer a an index fund
for the semiconductor index where if you
have semiconductor stocks outperforming
that scenario grade that's a good way
for investors to possibly hedge their
portfolio fine but geopolitically what
do we do that's actually much more much
more complicated question what do you
think the US would do so I'm debate I go
back and forth on this um I think that
there's a couple complicated
considerations
I think it depends on whether you think
China cares more about finishing its
unfinished business of reunifying that's
what they call it reunification of
Taiwan and the unfinished business of
its Civil War do they care more about
that as a national pride issue and a
domestic piece of cultural unfinished
business
more than they care about owning the
global semiconductor supply chain which
gives them a great competitive advantage
on a forward-looking basis so if they
care about the backward looking
finishing business more that dictates
one U.S policy and I'll say what that is
if they care more about the
forward-looking great power struggle
with the United States which allows them
to control the global semiconductor
supply chain that dictates a different
policy in the United States so I can go
through each intern okay
let's say it's the latter if they care
more about the global semiconductor
supply chain and the great power
struggle with the United States my gut
is I think that's what Xi Jinping
probably cares more about looking to the
Future than to the Past
in this case I think it becomes really
important for the us to do two things
one is Shore up our own domestic
semiconductor production capabilities
now and do it in the meantime make sure
that they don't invade Taiwan full stop
okay
there's some extreme things one could do
here I mean there's some interesting
ideas I mean you could buy those
semiconductor companies in Taiwan it
locks the US government could buy them
or fund other parties to buy them bring
those companies over here and prepare
for that now get ahead of that and by
the way you know China's probably not
militarily quite ready to take over
Taiwan in the next six to 12 months but
you know 12 months onward all bets are
off that's something the us could do the
US also by the way has I think this hair
brained policy in the U.S Navy right now
of the divest to invest program where we
are literally actively decommissioning
ships right you talk about the Nancy
Pelosi visit to Taiwan
the very ships that we flaunted in that
China Taiwan Strait the Taiwanese
straight
are probably going to be decommissioned
by the time that China actually invades
Taiwan because the divesty invest
program says we need to up the game of
our Fleet the technological advances
were behind that's gonna only happen
after 2030. so I think Xi Jinping is
looking for when are we going to be at a
Nader at our actual naval fleet versus
by the way China's Navy has actually
surpassed that the United States by as
measured by a number of ships in the
fleet when is that Delta going to be
highest that could be a pretty good
window to go to that could be in the
2025-2026 2027 time frame is he
anticipating military war I think either
side wants military war yeah I think the
other side wants military war so I think
the way this works in the version of the
world where China cares more about
upending the United States one up in the
United States on having control of the
semiconductor supply chain is something
like this China waits for you know some
window either maybe it's before the
Taiwanese election maybe it's before the
U.S presidential election or maybe they
wait for both of those to hit the U.S to
hit a Nader on our Naval uh capabilities
as part of our divesty invest program
Nader but somewhere in that window next
called the next you know five-ish years
they probably blockade Taiwan
and then Xi Jinping at some point picks
up the phone calls the time when he's
President says okay here's how it's
going to go down you're going to be
completely blockaded from from your
economy is going to be sequestered from
the rest of the world we've militarily
blockaded you and on the other hand if
you rejoin like we did and this is where
the history Matters by the way remember
that Civil War I told you they were in
Civil War for 20 years they still joined
forces to stand up to Japan they put
that on pause for eight years before
going back to war so one of those
moments of let's reunify here's what I
can do for you personally here's what I
can do and we'll do for your people
let's make this one nation again or else
you're going to be blockade and isolated
and it's going to be hell and miserable
for you and by the way if you don't do
it we're just gonna invade anyway
I think it's possible depending on what
the carrots and sticks are in that that
they would have a peaceful reunification
to borrow XI jinping's I mean I I cringe
as I use that word but I'm looking at
from a China perspective achieve that
reunification and then they show up to
the United States and say hey guess what
rules have changed a little bit guys uh
we have a grand bargain for you I don't
think they want to go to war with the
United States I think I think we have a
grand bargain for you
you know all the intellectual property
we've been trying to steal by planting
moles in your companies and people
running around with notebooks and flying
back to China I mean that that wasn't
working too well for us anyway it wasn't
that way of great of stealing
intellectual property anyway here's the
grand bargain
we make your stuff
and you give us your IP
China came to us with that grand bargain
now we would laugh them off the stage
because we can still have our stuff made
somewhere else but we can't have our
semiconductors made somewhere else and
our Modern Way of electronic Modern Life
depends on the semiconductors this is
what China puts China in the position to
come to that grand bargain and say that
okay now we've got Taiwan we did it
peacefully China doesn't want to go to
war with Taiwan because if there's a
risk that even tsmc is destroyed China's
screwed then too both China and the US
probably go into depression in that
scenario okay and and Taiwan calls tsmc
they're still in their semiconductor
industry their silicon Shield what does
that mean they're effectively implying
that they would kind of it's like
holding a gun to your own head is
hostage almost like they would turn the
lights off if China did invade and that
screws both China and the US enough but
if China is able to do the bear hug
approach to be able to peacefully do
this on a negotiated basis with Taiwan
that allows them to I think achieve the
real grand bargain with the United
States and what would it look like for
the ussen IP there well I mean
everything that we invest in our
competitive advantage on the global
stage is then gone we share that compare
we then share that competitive Advantage
with China so our knowledge economy our
key competitive Advantage economically
in the global stage is completely a
shared asset then with China and China
then achieves what its long-run next
step is which isn't to be the global
single Global hegemon that's maybe the
thousand year plan but they achieved a
hundred year plan which is to be on
equal parity and footing with the United
States we're mutually codependent on one
another
wasn't where the U.S was 20 years ago
wasn't where the U.S was 10 years ago
isn't even where the U.S is now we have
the upper hand that changes that's
that's the version of the world where
they care more about actually achieving
parity with the United States and I
think that's the right state of the
world but I go back and forth when you
look at this through the Chinese
historical lens does he care more about
the Chinese history and the
nationalistic identity and finishing Mao
zedong's unfinished work in that view of
the world
the story completely changes it's kind
of fascinating
where he doesn't care about the
semiconductor industry he cares about
this unfinished business between the
Chinese civil war between Mao Zedong and
Chiang Kai-shek and we need to reunify
for the sake of that Legacy
and if he cares about that more the
thing you do in China is say let the US
have the semiconductors wait for the U.S
to achieve self-sufficiency on the
semiconductor industry like give the US
time to catch up such that when we do go
for Taiwan they don't care they're not
going to stop us
so so I think it really matters to
understand which Xi Jinping
is it would be wild it seems to care
more about
but we don't understand
that's why I don't think that I don't
think that's what's going on here but
but this is so important that you've
just got to try on each set of clothes
yeah each lens and see it and and the
funny thing is you try on the two sets
of lenses here it's a totally different
answer in terms of what we're supposed
to do and what China would do yeah I've
I've never heard anyone talk about the
blockade and then uh the negotiated uh I
think that's what's gonna happen
approach and when that happens I guess
what becomes interesting about it is
like you basically have to do it so
quickly that the US doesn't have time to
act to you know break the blockade or
engage in any sort of military fight
which uh I don't think the appetite on
either side to your point uh appears at
least from the information we have
publicly uh to be that High
um but
if there is that uh uh coming together
their words you know reunification or
whatever
you mentioned the Civil War when they
came together and paused that Civil War
it was a pause for eight years and they
fought and then they went backwards is
the thought process here that the uh the
Olive Branch would be let's come
together for five or ten years let's
fight the us together I don't think it's
that I think I think that I think that
if he's prioritizing this it would be
kind of this is the end this would be
this is the end game the reunification
yeah today's episode is brought to you
by Exodus you can use exodus to buy
crypto for zero fees for a limited time
they just launched a brand new wallet
that allows you to use one wallet across
all the different networks ethereum
Solana polygon or whatever else you want
to use if you go to exodus.com pump you
can go ahead and use that wallet or you
can buy Bitcoin ethereum or any other
crypto asset you can use your bank
account your credit card Apple pay or
Google pay Exodus is here for you head
on over to exodus.com pomp today to get
started exodus.com pump they support us
you go support them and you know there
are thousand year strategy to supersede
the United States but for you know we're
talking on century rather than
Millennial time frames this is a pretty
good destination we're at equal parity
with the United States we control the
global semiconductor supply chain we've
achieved reunification get that grand
bargain and we're co-equals I don't
think China wants to go to war and the
US I don't think the US wants to go to
war and so I think who would win
so it's a good question uh it's a good
question right now I think the
conventional wisdom and so I've I've you
know gotten to know a lot of the you
know top US policy makers people serving
the last Administration people are
knowledgeable about this they will all
tell me till till the you know till
their face goes blue that the US is
definitely you know set up to win this
I'm not so sure actually when it look at
when you look at the
let's look at the naval capabilities
I mean they have a bigger Navy than ours
ships aren't everything quality matters
too but I think a lot of their ships are
also more technologically enabled than
ours that's why we are embarking on this
divest to invest program we're literally
on a downward slope right now in our
Naval capabilities
so it depends on how much military
strategy we want to get into here but I
think that this is where India comes
into the story it's kind of interesting
nobody it is if I haven't had this kind
of in-depth conversations this is fun
for me but um
but you know if we're getting too
detailed just tell me but why does India
where China's vulnerability comes in is
they still need to get their oil
supplies from the Middle East
that goes through the Indian Ocean okay
so so if if India size with the United
States I think China loses if India
sides with China I think China wins
and so this is com it's kind of
complicated but if India is is Lock
Stock and Barrel with the United States
with the United States wanting data do
and partner with India to do is to
blockade that Indian Ocean passageway
for just like Middle Eastern Oil to get
to China and other supplies you know
Crossing through the Indian Ocean
now I think that this curse this gets
another question of what the Chinese
prioritization is do they care more
about Taiwan or do they care more about
some of those regions in Northern India
that they took over in the indo-chinese
wars in in the you know latter half of
the 20th century
you know they took over a lot of
territories in Northeast India areas of
ladakh you talk about what's happening
in Tibet I mean China does care about
that they fought Wars to to secure that
added territory but the only version of
the world in which India I think doesn't
go with the United States I mean in the
US should be natural allies but there's
a complicated history with some love
lost there based on the US's support of
Pakistan during the Cold War vis-a-vis
Russia right so
you know he needed Pakistan or famously
you know Arch enemies or historically
have been Arch enemies one quick comment
on this uh I went to India and I was
blown away that they have the ceremonial
Face-Off at the border uh every single I
think it's morning and night that's
right and uh I was watching a video
somebody explaining to me and everything
yeah yeah and I was like wait hold on a
second here so like they actually don't
like each other but they still like
cooperate in the ceremonial thing or
whatever and I was like you play like
sports or Cricket they have like cricket
matches between the two or I was like
holy [ __ ] like I don't understand like
I'm just like so out of my element but
it just fascinated me that it has its
own history and you know I think that I
think that it's gone through rocker
times in more Peaceable times but the
India Pakistan rivalry is is well known
but that dates back to the Cold War
where the United States actually cited
more with arming Pakistan because India
was proceeding more allied with the
Soviet Union and so that I think has
eroded what otherwise should and would
have been a natural trust between I
think Global democracies like Israel
India Japan United States Australia I
think that
I think that there's a possibility for a
deeper Allegiance between the world's
self-governing democratic nations than
has obtained in the past NATO I think is
outdated in its relevance relative to I
think what what I think could be a
pan-democratic you know Alliance
vis-a-vis checking China's power that's
where the US I think should go because
the Indian Ocean matters in the battle
versus Taiwan now let's say that India
gets the deal done with China in Reverse
to get say those territories back some
sort of peace agreement for India to get
what it needs out of China and and the
skept and is more skeptical of the
United States as a reliable partner
then I think China wins the war because
I think with the US on over Taiwan and
the US may even conclude that which is
why the U.S may not even go to war over
Taiwan
so I think India if you ask the question
of who's going to win I think China has
an edge on us on the ships China has an
edge on us even supersonic missiles this
is another area where the United States
is dramatically behind is in our
supersonic missile capabilities these
are missiles that travel travel faster
than the speed of sound and can carry
you know nuclear warheads if necessary
you know war is a game of poker right
which we ultimately play the hand you
have I think the US has a weaker hand
than we realize in our military it's not
it's not 1946 anymore right and so I
think that that uh you know tips into
the calculus which makes
India's ability to potentially blockade
the Indian Ocean a big factor in whether
or not the U.S is in a position to
actually win a putative war that we'd go
to in Taiwan but I don't I think it's
all that's going to happen more or less
in a negotiated settlement in the shadow
of what each side believes its hand is
in the case of actually going to war
which
um
in Conflict uh there's a Navy SEAL
Marcus Luttrell who uh he's got this uh
famous uh video went super far on the
internet uh and what he talks about us
he says you know I'm a Warfighter right
he goes I do some nasty [ __ ] I was
trained by my government to do that
nasty [ __ ]
you better spend every single waking
second doing everything you can possibly
do on the Diplomatic front before you
call me because when you send me a hell
Fury and death to wherever you send me
I'm gonna be really honest I I I'm happy
to hear people like that still exist in
our military yes that sounds pretty good
to me yeah because we're gonna need them
that's what they're doing on the other
side and so this is a guy who uh uh the
movie Lone Survivor he is the lone
survivor he's the guy he's one of the
the four seals who ends up Surviving so
he's been through a lot of [ __ ] and all
stuff and his point in this is uh
everyone wants when conflict arise
let's send the military right the
military the military all the stuff and
everything and he's like listen
you don't understand what that entails
you should try everything else and this
is the last resort the violence is the
last resort because it's nasty and it
feeds into you know uh uh there's all
the controversy around the seal training
now and kind of all the craziness uh
about how it's too hard yeah of course
there was this there was this Yale kid
who you know joined and then died during
training and yes yeah and so that
they've had seals on we've talked about
it right like all these different things
but what I think it ultimately just
feeds back to is this thing of like if
we are going to go to war uh that has to
be the last resort right and the reason
why we want to have people who are
trained in a certain way is because we
were asking them to do the most
impossible task in the world yeah and so
the Diplomatic kind of uh Game Theory
the chess becomes incredibly important
vital vital because actually in the
outcome like disparity like 90 of the
outcomes are not military conflict
totally diplomatic one shade of
difference and just understanding I mean
if I had one wish of what I would want
to know right let's say let's say I'm
you know calling the shots here and
someone else calling the shots there the
thing I would in to see the person's
calling the shots for us the number one
factor that we need to understand
is which is Xi jinping's higher priority
is it achieving his unfinished business
from the Chinese Civil War of the 20th
century
or is it gaining the technological upper
hand in semiconductor production when it
comes to the great power struggle with
the United States in the 21st century if
we know which one he prioritizes more
and by the way it's increasingly about
this one man right it used to be the
party system but he's now taken this
third term over I mean China's really
heading to is already as of this month I
think basically an autocratic state
if we understand what that
prioritization is we're going to be able
to make a better decision either way the
path runs through self-reliance for us
on the semiconductor industry is the
thing that we need to do to prepare for
either a wartime scenario where tsmc is
blown up or whatever or a scenario where
China's just 10 hurry up guys and get it
done already so that we know that you're
not going to actually go to war over
this so we can invade Taiwan in either
of the two scenarios that's that's what
this points to and you know
more mundane matters but as it relates
to Capital markets great way for
investors to also at least you know
achieve a hedge and protect themselves
that's why we created this Index Fund
Etc but that's that's that's just you
know boring commercial stuff but I think
that the the substance of this of how
the U.S policy makers are to respond I
think depends on which Xi Jinping shows
up when it comes to the debate about
what they do in Taiwan
until very recently and even still I
would say that like it's so hard for me
to be imagine being in his shoes to say
that it would be anything other than the
forward-looking approach but it pres
that that view presumes a hubris to
think that he would think like you or I
would think or like an average American
would think
when
he has very complex motivations I mean
I've been reading I've been studying his
own uh biography for that reason a
little bit more it's a very complication
relation complicated relationship with
MAO are you familiar with this uh not
with their relationship no so so his his
father was persecuted by Mao
and he was like banished to the
countryside
and you know his family was actually as
part of the cultural revolution was was
actually physically harassed Etc by
students he didn't see his dad his dad
went to be tortured he only saw his dad
much later in life and his dad you know
barely didn't recognize his kids I mean
he could kill been through a lot that
that no one knows exactly what he went
through there was one instance where
apparently Xi Jinping had to like wear
like a tin hat of Shame on his head in
front of a large audience that was sort
of insulting him as a child of sort of
the elite class that Mao Zedong actually
encouraged the students in the uprising
of the cultural revolution to turn
against and so so he has this
complicated relationship with MAO but
then he also kind of idolizes Mao and
you know even some of the some of the
clothing he wears emulates the kind of
clothing that Mao wore and it's just
like complicated daddy complex that he's
got with MAO
um and and it's and and I don't have all
the answers yet but I think I think
we've got to be able to put ourselves in
his shoes to understand whether he cares
more about besting the United States or
about completing that unfinished
business whatever you know Freudian
analysis there is to do I mean I think
human beings are human beings in the end
whether they're Chinese or American and
they're you know a lot of their
motivations date back to you know their
childhood and their upbringing and
there's a lot going on in his childhood
and upbringing yeah if we can just
understand that better I think we can
make vastly better decisions that could
you know save lives save our economy if
we can be more precise about wrapping
our head around that and that's why I
mean it's kind of I would like to hope
that there are that this is what our
policy makers in the state department
Etc are focused on
you'd hope but you know I mean one
citizen among many trying to learn as
much as I can about this did you read uh
the long game uh it's uh I didn't read
it but I'm familiar with you yeah what
was the theme it's difficult to read um
I've heard Most of It kind of dense uh
super dense it's translated I mean it's
just like it's just if you're gonna read
anything this is like one of the harder
things to read but uh one of the big
takeaways is just the long-term thinking
right I mean and it's just like and it's
like little things it's not even
explicit all the time but like all of
these components and I was recently
having a conversation uh uh with a
friend and and he kept talking about uh
if that compounds for 20 years and and
and it blew me away because I don't have
a lot of friends who think uh about you
know 10 or 20 year time frames right and
then 100 years in contrast of you know
these guys think a hundred and thousand
years and so it was like oh wow like
this person that I really respect uh
here in the United States he thinks in
10 and 20 of your time frames like
amazing how of a long-term thinker
and it's just a different game
here's the interesting part about this
though on the bright side for us from an
American perspective at least is
when you combine autocratic hubris with
long-term thinking you can actually get
to dangerous places for yourself too
right because short-term yeah yeah at
least the short term I can foresee but
but she's being okay well now I'm really
in charge and I everything's gonna go
exactly as I planned for a thousand
years that's the demise of most
autocracies is the ego and the hubris of
the guy who thinks he has it all mapped
out so in a certain sense that could
also be they could be their strength can
be their Achilles heel too and so
there's a lot of kinks in our system
that they know how to exploit right out
that Trojan Horse our love for that
trojan horse that they served us up that
I talked about earlier but there are
kinks in their system too and I think a
lot of that relates to the ego and the
psychological and personal motivations
of Xi Jinping like let's say I mean
let's let's say it was that second state
of the world where he actually cares
more about closing up his unfinished
business and and you know the Mao daddy
complex that he has and and you know
invading Taiwan for that or peaceful
annexing Taiwan or whatever for that
reason
that'd be a Big Boon for the United
States because that means he's letting
us and giving us the opportunity to
build up our semiconductor industry
because his priority is to know that
once we're self-sufficient enough he
knows that we're not going to get in his
way that actually might actually be in
the great power struggle what what would
give us that competitive Advantage so
I'm not sure that's where his head space
is on that narrow issue but history
would teach us that it is the hubris of
the autocratic dictator who thinks he's
also able to plan for a hundred a
thousand years that actually leads to
the ultimate demise in their calculus
and so far it's worked all right for his
rise but there will be a point in time
where that could itself be a
vulnerability too so we have kinks in
our system and kinks in our armor but
they have some kinks in theirs too and I
think the more aware we are of theirs I
think we're less aware of theirs than
they are of ours yeah but the more
awareness we gain of theirs the more
we're going to be able to make effective
you know military decisions yeah and
economic decisions last thing I want to
talk about uh Bitcoin uh I have no clue
what your views on bitcoin are uh
positive negative anywhere in between
we're still figuring it out so I'm not
gonna I'm not shy about uh about
spouting off in areas where I think I
have expertise which are which are
diverse uh you know if I may say so
myself but bitcoin's not one of them um
I'm I'm still like a nascent student
I'll give you my my Impressions maybe
everyone I was hoping to do was to learn
a little bit from you even from our from
our chat here so some favorably disposed
very favorably disposed to the idea of
having
competition with
Central Fiat money I think that
competition is going to be good I didn't
think that you would uh be against that
yeah but I'm like quite strongly in
favor of of that proposition
you know without repeating boarding
platitudes that you know more of your
you know presumably pro-bitcoin audience
is already on board with like you know I
could maybe focus on one of the areas of
of
limited
um Outsider feedback here that I think
that the Bitcoin proponents I worry uh
ask it to do too much interesting yeah
well we've sort of put too much on
bitcoin's shoulders
right I I think I think the end of
competing with Fiat money sort of that
as an end that is a goal is a worthy
enough goal for what that can accomplish
for human flourishing and for economic
freedom and for autonomy and for even
economic prosperity
and and keeping you know Central
governments in check with respect to you
know Federal Reserve in the United
States et cetera in check with respect
to behaviors that otherwise create a um
you know I think a form of hubris of Our
Own but I think that you know some
sometimes when I hear from from
bitcoiners is that a term you use like
Bitcoin yeah is is sort of the belief
that like when I'm talking about you
know the the cultural challenges from
ESG to challenges in American culture to
these victimhood narratives is Bitcoin
is the answer decentralization is the
answer Bitcoin solves this Bitcoin
solves this and I think that that's
asking too much of a currency I mean at
the end of the day you're creating a new
form of paper right it's a new form of
paper that competes with the old forms
of paper but you know gold is still
paper Bitcoin is still paper at the end
maybe you know maybe maybe don't agree
with that but I think that at the end of
the day these are just different forms
of paper that compete with one another
and I think that the idea that that's
somehow going to solve challenges that
are fundamentally cultural in nature
makes a bit of an error in conflating
cultural or normative challenges with
technocratic ones yeah and I think we
got to be careful about that so so
what's interesting um you're probably
talking to the best and worst person
about these uh because uh on some
aspects uh I think that my views uh
align uh and would be completely 100
agreed upon uh with almost any bitcoiner
you would talk to so many of the things
around decentralization around
competition uh with Fiat centralized
currencies like all of that stuff yeah
uh uh I think I'm in line with and
understand uh and agree with the part
that I think
around Bitcoin solves this
what the Bitcoin argument would be is
that many of societal problems that we
Face are all traced back to the
corruption of money so if you basically
take a first principles approach right
uh the argument would be uh why is there
an obesity problem in America well you
can trace it back through the food
system through you know corporate greed
through all stuff and like you
eventually just get to like there's a
Corruption of money and like if you
solve the corruption of money then
eventually you can solve that problem
right yeah and so like I see that
argument yeah right and uh I am
sympathetic to that argument I actually
in fact would uh like it to be that
simple yeah exactly if only it worked
but but
it's a weird thing and where maybe uh I
have views that maybe some bitcoiners
don't agree with is that like
theoretically that is true in reality
there's other things there's additional
steps and maybe this is kind of what
you're getting at which is like yes I a
first principle solution to that problem
is fix the money right so fix the money
fix the world it's kind of the the talk
yeah and and for the most part like
actually like I do think the corruption
of money has like immense negative
impacts on all sorts of you know crazy
parts of society that don't seem
connected but they are
but Bitcoin alone I don't think is
enough to solve some of these problems
because you need other Solutions as well
right and am I wrong or do you get the
sense that a lot of bitcoiners kind of
believe it is like it is a little bit of
like a Panacea too it was it's just a
theoretical uh uh it's a theoretical
belief that if you simply solve the
correctional money the the cascading
impact is possible so here's why I am I
believe the corruption of money is the
source of a lot of problems actually my
latest book does talk extensively about
this even in the modern American context
however
I don't believe it's responsible for all
of our problems and I think that there's
a different problem that I'm focused on
uh that I focused on my first book which
is that I also think there's a different
problem going on in our country in our
modern contemporary culture right now
which is that you know how old are you
men you're 34 34 okay you're younger
than I am 37 right but we're part of
this generation you're old yeah exactly
30 late 30s that's the difference
between late and early 30s we're both
Millennials you're Millennial right
that's still Millennial oh yeah okay
yeah yeah Millennial and younger is
we are hungry we're so hungry for a
Cause
we're all so hungry for purpose and
meaning
and identity and belonging
that the kinds of things and by the way
we're living in a moment where the the
source of things that used to fill that
hunger for purpose and meaning and
identity like
the f word faith you know patriotism
national identity hard work family
whatever it might have been I mean those
things are undoubtedly
receding in Modern Life it's my
theory of the case is that
there's a black hole of identity in our
generation in our American moment and
that's what allows
the isms to fill the void wokism
scientism which is different from
science right it's a belief
unquestioning belief and Authority but
but I worry that actually if we miss
that reality and just put it all in the
corruption of money and there's other
there's other views I have too of other
fundamental social
conundrums one of which is the
corruption of money but but there are
others too that if we just pin it all to
the corruption of money
Bitcoin becomes a new ISM and bitcoinism
just like wokeism or scientism or
whatever is going to fill that void of
hunger and purpose and meaning and
identity and sense for belonging
that is asking too much of a currency
that's not what occurrency was supposed
to do currency supposed to fix the
corruption of money by competing in the
marketplaces for currencies that's all
good I'm like whole hogging on that but
I think that where we where we sometimes
you know I don't think we as though I
feel like a newcomer but but a part of
the community anyway but where we
sometimes
um you know might
might Veer a little bit is expecting too
much out of it by thinking that that's
going to solve problems that are
fundamentally normative or moral or
cultural in nature and in the process
may actually
recreate some of the same cultural
failures that led us to that led to the
ESG informed world or that led it to the
to the the Dei influenced culture or
whatever it is that bitcoinism becomes a
new substitute secular religion that the
thing we love about it is the fact that
it's not a religion it's just a rational
path to autonomy when it comes to
relationship of money right and and we
don't need to and I see this a little
bit hey here's another place where I
sort of see evidence of this a little
bit is and you totally correct me if I'm
wrong because this is like I said at the
beginning of this section not my world
and so I'm still a new student here but
it seems to me like sometimes the
bitcoiners are trying to play the game
in the marketplace of ideas and the
debates and the critiques of Bitcoin oh
no we're green too oh oh no no we're
doing the diversity thing we have the
Bitcoin diversity thing and trying too
hard to sort of prove to the critics
that no no we're one of the good guys
when in fact you should just be yourself
this being good as being yourself
there's a uh a splitting I think kind of
if uh you know if Bitcoin is the macro
idea there are micro factions right
where uh some people are very much uh
yes we are uh uh ESG compliant we are
this we are that we are you know look
we're the good guys you know exactly and
then actually I think probably the
people who uh are a little bit more
hardcore Believers more libertarian in
nature those types of things they're
like
we reject your framework we we you know
[ __ ] do not Embrace that on me yeah just
like like consuming energy is good yeah
and by the way part of the reason I find
this attractive is precisely because it
is outside of the centralized systems
that enforce that one religious ideology
and a religion that I don't want to bend
the knee to yeah right so I'm kind of
there I'm kind of in that camp and I
sort of worry a little bit that the
Bitcoin solves everything movement one
of the things that's wrong with it is
that it also requires accommodating
these other agendas as a way of proving
that Bitcoin is compatible with if not
causally linked to solving problems
relating to racism or climate change
when in fact that wasn't what Bitcoin
was set up to do instead of to solve the
corruption of money solve that and do
that through competition and be yourself
rather than pretending to be something
you aren't so that's something that so
it sounds like I'm not 100 off then and
you are closer than you think and I'll
even give you uh kind of a personal
anecdote so uh uh over the last number
of years uh I was very outspoken uh
about Bitcoin and talked about it uh
over and over and over and over again uh
and at one point somebody came to me uh
and was like hey
um
you know Bitcoin in your bio on Twitter
well I never thought about that I never
put asset in my bio before right like
okay exactly but but I really respect
the person I was talking to and and they
were like you know uh you do whatever
you want but like it may be uh a good
thing for the community like you know
people would know that you're into
Bitcoin I'm like okay well that's pretty
much all I tweet about but like okay
yeah put it there and then uh the whole
laser eyes thing started and uh kid dm'd
me my own photo with laser eyes already
on it and I was like uh well if everyone
else is doing it then like sure right
like like ah cool whatever's fine and so
this all continued
I took the laser eyes off this year
Bitcoin out of the bio and I wrote
something because when I did it there
was like a concern
did he you know did he leave the
religion I mean Church no one said it
exactly in those terms but like there
was a little bit of like did he sell his
Bitcoin right did he give up does he not
believe anymore he's not a Believer and
all this and so I wrote a piece and I
just said listen uh you know aptly
titled uh um you know did I change my
mind on bitcoin right it's just like
let's get right to the heart of the
issue no I actually have more conviction
today than I ever have uh but uh there
was somebody who who had uh texted me at
one point he said uh why'd you take your
laser eyes off I said because I couldn't
see with them on as a way to basically
say just like listen uh
uh I think I am more valuable in talking
about it by being able to walk in and
say I don't have laser eyes I don't have
my identity tied up in this this is this
is this is so fun it's not unique to
bitcoin I think it's Unique to our
cultural moment where it is this idea
that you have to Signal the tribe you're
a part of Bitcoin is ought not be a
tribe it ought not be a faith it ought
not be a religion it ought to be a
currency that competes with Fiat money
to realize that to solve the problem the
corruption of money not more not less
and you know I see this sort of
cultishness
um like let's just leave Bitcoin for a
second but what you just said is like
you've seen the Republican party with
respect to like fealty to like one man
you see it in like the tech in certain
segments of the of the tech and
investing Community I think like a lot
of the Elon Musk followership has this
quality that if you're not believing in
like everything that he spouts off on a
given day that somehow you're not
Allegiant to everything else worthy that
he does and like I feel this I I I feel
like I smell I smell a little bit of
that in the in the uh Bitcoin is here's
what I would say here's what I would say
I am Pro Bitcoin I I'm I'm in the you
know what you call the purest Pro
libertarian don't you impose this
centralized set of values on me sense of
pro-bitcoin
and then
mildly skeptical of what I call
bitcoinism which is the which is the um
religionization of it that are you with
us or are you against us context concept
um I'm against Bitcoin victimhood
culture I'm against all forms of
victimhood cultures you know you
probably got from some of our earlier
discussions you wrote a book called
nation of victims I'm pretty sure that's
not your thing sort of you know I mean
like what else you can expect like you
do something new you're gonna have
you're gonna have arrows coming for you
toughen up and get over it I think you
mostly I think I think you know the
Bitcoin Community mostly is but I'm
against against the religiosity of it I
I'm skeptical of the religiosity of it
I'm skeptical of the of the sort of the
victimhood culture that they're that
they're coming for us attitude as
opposed to figuring out how we actually
you know achieve the solution to the
problem of the corruption of money but
at its Essence what the true thing is
I'm all about it and I think the uh the
superstructure we've created you know
there's there's the um use Freudian
psychology there's the ID there's the
ego and then the superego
I think that for the ID the thing itself
the true Essence I'm all in
for this ego structure that's been
created around it which is the sort of
the religiosity and the uh you know the
defensiveness of feeling like it's being
attacked I think it's a false structure
that's been created and then you know
there's the superego which is The
Regulators or whatever that say don't do
it you know you gotta you got to
superego always starts with don't you
know in your head like when you hear in
your own head you know don't do X it's
probably your you know parental Voice or
whatever telling you not to you know not
to be the true essence of yourself
I'm against the don't culture as well
which is to say that just because this
is new and uncontrollable that we're
going to be against it I'm rabidly
against that but I'm also even against
the ego shell that's kind of formed
around you know that's what I call the
bitcoinism versus the true essence of
what it is that's what I think we gotta
we gotta stay true to I I uh I find when
I have conversations uh with people both
uh incredibly prominent and also no one
even knows that they know anything about
Bitcoin uh the one commonality is that
regardless of where you are on uh the
spectrum of the religiosity yep
the essence of it is the the common
thread and if you had to choose you
would want the essence of the technology
to be the Common Thread rather than the
religiosity of it right obviously and so
uh it gives me hope that uh although
what I find fascinating about the entire
Community is there's uh people on the
left people on the right there's people
in the center there's people who don't
give a [ __ ] right there's there's uh
every race religion cree and it's just
like everything it's it is uh this
unifying thing for so many different
types of people that like the power of
the crowd actually is uh uh drastically
Mis uh uh underestimated or it's just
like underestimated by uh both the
incumbents and even the community itself
of like in 14 years look what's happened
so far and you have people all around
the world working and I always remind
folks like there are tens hundreds uh
thousands millions of nodes around the
world these mining machines Etc there is
no CEO there's no marketing department
there's no board of directors there's no
you know
balance sheets it's just the presence of
what it is it's just a bunch of weirdos
on the internet who all have a common
belief in something and they're doing
their part which I think is part of the
beauty of uh of this
um but they're voting their own voice
they're voting their voice that's right
that that's that's true Essence to sort
of a strive Mission as well yes exactly
match your voice with your actual
capital
that match is what strive is all about
creating so in that sense we're deeply
you know deeply deeply sort of
synchronous and aligned with the Bitcoin
Mission as well which I think is which I
think is pretty cool the one the one
area of food for thought it just occurs
to me also given that we went into such
depth with China and Taiwan here is that
I think there's a strand of certainly
um
you know the Bitcoin movement that
appropriately Rejects
fetishization of national identities
right this is this is you know trans
partisan as you said but it's also
transnational right and that's part of
what makes it beautiful is it's a
community of people that can transcend
National boundaries and reject the
oppression of Fiat and the corruption of
Fiat money as a concept wherever that
yeah money is coming from but I would
just I would inject one cautionary node
into this
which is to say that in the obsession
over the American reluctance to achieve
Bitcoin and thereby
you know I was reading you know Bitcoin
magazine or whatever it was called it
usually this article about like the rise
of the Petro dollar was pretty good
pretty good piece do you see that one uh
yeah I think Alex Gladstone yeah it's
about right that sounds about right yeah
it's so so so you know I learned a lot
from that piece that was pretty good but
um it had this sort of anti-nationalist
streak to it
from an American perspective
which I think can lead to a
um
lead to a self-defeating place where
let's say in that great power struggle
let's fast forward it let's let's do the
Chinese thing and think of longer term
Horizons here for a second let's fast
forward that 200 years
watch you know who's going to be opposed
to decentralized
autonomy in in in non-fiat currency it's
gonna be the future Chinese State it's
the CCP it's Xi Jinping and his progeny
of leadership and I think that if we're
if we're
um sowing the seeds for and I don't
think we are but I think we've got to be
careful about this this article had had
undertones of it of sort of rejecting
the importance of the preservation of
American National leadership
not only is that something that is uh
personally important to me is as a
category of Citizen sort of Wordly
American nationally nationalistic with
respect to the ideals that Define this
nation and all that good stuff but
forget that even from a bitcoiner
perspective
I think a world in which China rather
than the United States is the
is the leading hegemon
2045 is like 1945 except with China in
the position of the United States I
don't think it's a good or even tenable
future for the future of Bitcoin or
anything like it and I think it's
important that people in the
transnational the coolness of it being a
transnational Community not lose sight
of the fact that the boundaries between
the nation states that we have today are
still relevant to the future of Bitcoin
itself too and that are the guy wrote
that article which is otherwise a good
piece I think that's something that he
missed uh and I don't know if that's
representative of the broader Community
or not but if it is that would be one
you know I I always get into that
Bitcoin is unique in that um it has a
lot of the American ideals and Ethos
kind of uh codified yeah in the system
itself I think so I think so and it's
interesting because even if you were to
look at like the Bitcoin system and the
decentralization uh people will talk
about the hash rate and Mining and and
uh that is an important uh uh almost you
know I would are you essential piece of
Bitcoin and what sets it apart uh with
proof of work and the decentralization
but there's still checks and balances
it's a lot like the American political
system right like you have three bodies
of the US government in the Bitcoin
system if you want to change rules you
have the miners you have the nodes you
have the software operators that's right
and so you you get some of these
components that I think are just really
really powerful
um and we shouldn't shy away from that
we should if Bitcoin embodies these
American ethos then we should be a
leader I I I I I think so right exactly
but I think I think that that's the way
I would look at it yeah America should
want to be a leader yeah and it's not a
zero something like that doesn't mean
that nobody else can be a leader or
nobody else can Embrace
so why the heck are we regulating this
in a way that rejects the idea that we
want to be a leader in in going the way
the future I'm all in on that and that's
exactly the framing I prefer versus the
underturn at least in that little
article that I read was more in terms of
like this idea of
you know the outdatedness of national
boundaries and the idea of this new
transnational community that transcends
the otherwise American corruption that
you know created the petrodollar system
that perpetuated war and financed War I
I think he makes some compelling
arguments but I think that that is is
ultimately a self-defeating route to go
all the way down if It ultimately
contributes to the rise of other
hegemons that supplant the position of
the United States has filled
in a way that's going to be
self-defeating for Bitcoin itself if it
uh it was the human rights Foundation
um uh Al scottseen is the chief strategy
officer if it was uh him who wrote that
uh they've been very outspoken about the
uh uh the issues in China so uh it's
interesting in that like I'm saying it
more in terms of Less in terms of
uh impuning the goal but more in terms
of the two cents on tactics yep you know
to get there yeah it makes a complete
sense where can we send people to find
you on the internet yeah I mean uh you
know strive.com is a good place to start
to strive as the company I found it so
that's probably the easiest one to
remember
um but we have a Vivek ramaswamy.com
where my books are are online as well uh
I have I haven't been a big social media
guy but I got on social media a couple
years ago with Twitter you're very good
on Twitter yeah Twitter's the one that I
the only one that I that I use so I uh
Vivek at Vivek G ramaswamy and uh you
know check out strive.com if you wanted
to know what I'm spending my day job on
but if you want my ideas where I'm
spouting off about one topic or another
uh you know I usually I usually use
Twitter as my uh as my closet for an
idea that I get off my chest once in a
while so awesome well listen thank you
so much for your time I really enjoyed
this I learned a ton uh we'll have to do
it again in the future cool man thanks
for having me